A. I WELCOME TODAY'S
INFORMATIONAL HEARING TITLED
UTILIZATION OF EXCESS STATE
LAND FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING. AS
MANY OF YOU KNOW THE LACK OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IS ONE OF IF
NOT THE BIGGEST ISSUE FACING
CALIFORNIA TODAY. ACCORDING TO
STATE OFFICIALS FROM. TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN TO TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY FIVE
APPROXIMATELY ONE POINT EIGHT
MILLION NEW HOUSING UNITS ARE
NEEDED. TO MEET THE PROJECTED
POPULATION GROWTH OR A HUNDRED
EIGHTY THOUSAND HOMES ANNUALLY.
THIS NUMBER IS FAR HIGHER THAN
THE CURRENT AVERAGE OF EIGHTY
THOUSAND HOMES PER YEAR THAT
ARE CURRENTLY BEING BUILT IN
THE STATE CALIFORNIA. THE
IMPACT OF THE LACK OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IS WELL
DOCUMENTED OUR CONSTITUENTS OR
OVERPAYING FOR HOUSING COMMUTE
COMMUTING LONG DISTANCES
BETWEEN THEIR HOMES AND THEIR
WORK LIVING IS OVER IN
OVERCROWDED HOMES AND
UNFORTUNATELY EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. THE HIGH COST OF
HOUSING ALSO INCREASES
HEALTHCARE COSTS DECREASES
EDUCATIONAL OUTCOMES IT MAKES
IT VERY DIFFICULT FOR
CALIFORNIA BUSINESSES TO
ATTRACT AND RETAIN EMPLOYEES.
FACED WITH THIS ISSUE EARLIER
THIS YEAR GOVERNOR NEWSOME
SIGNED AN EXECUTIVE ORDER TO
DEVELOP AFFORDABLE HOUSING ON
ACCESS STATE LANDS. EXECUTIVE
ORDER DIRECTED THE DEPARTMENT
OF GENERAL SERVICES AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT TO
IDENTIFY AND PRIORITIZE ACCESS
STATE OWNED PROPERTY AND
AGGRESSIVELY PURSUE SUSTAINABLE
AND COST EFFECTIVE HOUSING
PROJECTS. IN APRIL TGS ARE
IDENTIFIED IN INITIAL INVENTORY
OF 440-003-0070 STATE OWNED
PARCELS THIRTEEN HUNDRED THIRTY
OF WHICH WERE FLIGHT IS
POTENTIALLY VIABLE FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPMENT.
IT IS MY UNDERSTANDING THE D.
G. S. H. ET ARE CURRENTLY IN
THE PROCESS OF REVIEWING THOSE
PARCELS AND BEGINNING IN
SEPTEMBER WILL ISSUE A REQUEST
FOR PROPOSALS AND BEGIN THE
DEVELOPMENTAL. DEVELOPMENT
PROCESS AS WE WORK TO SOLVE THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING CRISIS IN
CALIFORNIA I'M HOPEFUL THE
STATE WILL WORK COOPERATIVELY
WITH OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING
ORGANIZATIONS TO FIND CREATIVE
SOLUTIONS TO THESE VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUES THAT WE FACE.
AS SUCH I HOPE TODAY'S HEARING
WILL PROVIDE THE LEGISLATURE
MEMBERS THE PUBLIC WITH AN
UPDATE AS TO THE STATUS OF THE
GOAL SET FORTH BY THE EXECUTIVE
ORDER AND ALLOW LOCAL
GOVERNMENT IN AFFORDABLE
HOUSING ORGANIZATIONS WITH THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE THEIR
VIEWS ON THE EXECUTIVE ORDER.
LET ME THANK ALL THE WITNESSES
ADVANCE FOR BEING HERE TODAY IF
THE REPRESENTATIVES FROM TGS
ACD. COULD PLEASE COME FORWARD
NOW SO WE CAN BEGIN. THOSE.
MORNING MR CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR HAVING
US EXCITED TO BE ABLE TO
PRESENT AN EXECUTIVE ORDER.
EVERYONE CAN SEE OVER MY HEAD
I'M ASSUMING PERFECT SO. THE
FIRST THING I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
AND BY THE WAY I'M HAPPY TO
MAKE THIS INTERACTIVE IF YOU'VE
GOT A QUESTION YOU WANT TO ASK
IN THE MIDDLE OF IT PLEASE FEEL
FREE TO INTERJECT AS OPPOSED TO
WAITING TO THE END BUT THE
FIRST THING I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
JUST HIGHLIGHTS OF THE
EXECUTIVE ORDER IN PARTICULAR
WHY THIS IS A FIRST OF ITS KIND
PROPERTY INVENTORY SO A LITTLE
BACKGROUND THE STATE STATUTORY
FRAMEWORK FOR PROPERTY I'M
PAINTING WITH A BROAD BRUSH
HERE IS PRETTY SIMPLE. STATE OF
CALIFORNIA OWNS PROPERTY AND
THE PROPERTY IS INVESTED WITH
DEPARTMENT PRESSED TO UTILIZE
THAT PROPERTY IN FURTHERANCE OF
THEIR MISSION SO DMD FOR
EXAMPLE DMV OWNS A DMB DOES NOT
APPLY LENDS THAT CALIFORNIA
OWNS A PLOT OF LAND THAT LAND
IS ENTRUSTED TO DMB. TO UTILIZE
IT FOR SAY A FIELD OFFICE. AND
IT'S UNDER THEIR JURISDICTIONS
OPERATIONAL CONTROL. AT SOME
POINT IN TIME THOUGH THAT LAND
NO LONGER SERVICES THEIR NEEDS
MAY BE THEIR CONSTITUENTS
CHANGE MAY BE THE CITY HAS
MOVED A LITTLE BIT NORTHWARD
MAYBE NEED A BIGGER OFFICE
WHATEVER THE CASE MAY BE THAT
PROPERTY NO LONGER SERVICES
THEIR NEEDS. AND THEY WOULD
THEN DECLARE ACCESS ONCE A
DEPARTMENT DECLARED PROPERTY TO
BE EXCESS AGAIN IT'S REALLY
DUMB SAYING. THIS PROPERTY
STILL BELONG THE STATE SHOULD
BE STATE PROPERTY BUT WE DON'T
NEED IT ANYMORE. TGS GETS
TAGGED TO COME IN AND
FACILITATE A- OF THE BEGINNING
OF A DISPOSITION PROCESS AND
THE INITIAL STEPS AND STATURE
SENSUALLY ARE TO LOOK AT OTHER
STATE. READ THIS. MAYBE DMB
DOESN'T NEED IT A. B. C. H. P.
DOES MAYBE E. D. TO. THOSE
SORTS OF THINGS WE ALSO CAN
LOOK AT LONG TERM LEASING
DEPENDING ON THE NATURE OF THE
PROPERTY AND- WHETHER IT'S
NEEDED. NOW MAYBE NOT BUT MAYBE
IN THE FUTURE AT SOME POINT
TIME WE DON'T WANNA GET RID OF
THE PROPERTY WE CAN ENTER TO
SOME SORT OF MEDIUM OR LONG
TERM LEAST TO SORT OF. CONTINUE
UTILIZATION. BUT IN THE DAY. WE
START LOOKING AT EITHER STATE
RE USE OR OR LEASING. ONCE THAT
FAILS. IF THAT FAILS I WOULD
SAY FOR MOST PARTS. PROPERTIES
OFTEN TRANSFERRED OTHER STATE
AGENCIES IT IS MOST COMMON.
THAT DO A NUMBER OF FACTORS
THEY THEN GO TO THE NEXT THE.
PROCESS OF. GOING TO A
DIFFERENT AGENCY. IS AN THE
CARD. THE LEGISLATURE. AT THAT
POINT IN TIME THE STATE IS
AUTHORIZED TO POTENTIALLY A
SAID THERE'S NO LAW FIRST. AS
THE STATE'S AUTHORIZED TO
DISPOSITION THE PROPERTY IN A
VARIETY OF WAYS WERE THAT
SAILED TRANSFERS EXCHANGE
ACOSTA LEAST AND DO THINGS LIKE
THAT WE CAN STILL GIVE IT TO A
STATE DEPARTMENT. AVENUE NEED
COMES UP BUT FOR THE MOST PART
WANT SOMETHING A SURPLUS FOR
AUTHORIZED TO DISPOSE OF IT NOW
IN THE IN WHATEVER WAY BENEFITS
THE STATE. THIS IS THE FOR THE
FRAMEWORK PROCESS AND EVERY
YEAR DEPARTMENTS TYPICALLY
DECLARE SOME NUMBER OF
PROPERTIES BE ACCESS. BUT IT
MIGHT BE ONE MIGHT BE TO FORCE
A REALLY GOOD YEAR THERE'S NOT
A WHOLE. WE WERE WE GET THE-
CAR IN THE ACCESS. TO THE
EXECUTIVE ORDER SAID WAS LET'S
GO TAKE A PROACTIVE LOOK
REGARDLESS OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
DECLARING LET'S REALLY DIG INTO
WHAT PROPERTIES ARE OUT THERE
WHAT MIGHT BE UNDER UTILIZED
WERE NOT BEING UTILIZED AT ALL
AND WHAT COULD BE TERMED ACCESS
AND- REINVIGORATED FOR HOUSING.
I SHOULD KNOW TO. IN THE SUCH
STORES FOR SURPLUS POSSIBLE
LOADING ORGANIZATION.
LEGISLATURE HAS DIRECTED TO THE
HOUSE. THE. THESE PROPERTY
THAT'S NO LONGER NEED BY THE
STATE. SO WE DID A- ACTIVE LOOK
ALL TALK ABOUT THE RESULTS OF
THAT LOOKING ALL TALK ABOUT
KIND OF HOW WE APPROACHED IN A
SLIDER TO BUT THIS REALLY IS A
FIRST OF ITS KIND INVENTORY OF
STATE PROPERTY THAT HAS BEEN
DONE BEFORE WHICH WERE VERY
EXCITED TO SHARE DETAILS ON.
I'M THE EXECUTIVE ORDER ALSO
JUST KIND OF BACK TO THIS LINE
HIGHLIGHTS IT DOES REQUIRE A
VERY SYSTEMATIC AN OBJECTIVE
APPROACH THE PROPERTY WE DID
APPROACH THIS LIKE A FINAL AND
I THINK IT'LL BE MADE CLEAR AS
THE PRESENTATION CONTINUES BUT
IT ALSO TALKS ABOUT HOW WE GO
ABOUT DEVELOPING SO IT FOCUSES
ON INNOVATIVE CONSTRUCTION
APPROACHES WHETHER THAT
SUSTAINABLE PRO WORKFORCE
CENTER FOR. EQUITABLE PRO
APPROACH IT DOES. ON ON
PARTNERSHIP OF THE PRINCE. IT'S
PLAYED OUT SO FAR AND HOW THAT
WILL PLAY OUT IN THE AND IT
REALLY DOES FOCUS ON EXPEDITED
DEVELOPMENTS. THERE'S NO WAY
YOU WHATEVER THE FINAL NUMBER
OF UP TO. BE THAT THEY'RE ALL
GONNA HAPPEN AT ONCE THIS IS
GONNA BE A PERIOD OF TIME BUT
OBVIOUSLY IN OUR PRIORITIZATION
EFFORTS WERE FOCUSING ON THE
THINGS THAT CAN GET DONE SOONER
THAN LATER. SO WE CAN GET AS
MUCH BUILT IN THE SHORT TERM AS
WELL AS THE MEDIUM TO LONG TERM.
SO WHAT. WE'VE DONE AND WHERE
WE GOING. SO THE INITIAL
INVENTORY AS SENATOR ROBB
MENTIONED WAS INITIALLY
COMPLETED. 440-003-0070 PARCELS
USING COUNTY ASSESSOR DATA WERE
VISUALLY LOOKED AT WITH A TEAM
OF NINE PEOPLE DEDICATED FOR
THREE MONTHS DOING EXACTLY
THAT. THEY PULLED A SHEET FILES
WHICH ARE BASICALLY VISUAL.
VIEWS THE PARCELS. AND THEY
WERE LOOKING FOR UTILIZATION.
OR LACK THERE OF. AND THEY WERE
LOOKING FOR PRETTY LIBERAL.
FACTORS THAT INDICATE THE
HOUSING MIGHT BE VIABLE THERE
SO IT'S A LITTLE FACTORS I MEAN
WE DELIBERATELY TRY TO PULL IN
MORE. PROPERTIES THAN BEING IN
A- FORM EXCLUSIONARY THAT PUT
IN THE PROCESS. SO IF SOMETHING
WAS. WATER LITERALLY IT'S
OBVIOUSLY NOW. IF SOMETHING'S
IN THE MOUNTAINS SOMEWHERE IN
THE FOREST IS OBVIOUSLY NO BUT
IF. YOU KNOW IN A IN A QUOTE.
FOR URBAN AREA CRITICALLY
SOMETHING THAT'S THE. LEAST
GENERALLY CLOSE TO RESIDENTIAL
HE GOT INCLUDED IN. KIND OF
MAKING A VENN DIAGRAM IN YOUR
HEADS IT'S WHERE DOES PROPERTY
SEEM TO BE UNDER UTILIZED. AND
THEN WHERE DOES DEVELOPMENT
SEEM TO BE VIABLE FROM HIGH
LEVEL WE DID EXCLUDE PARCELS
THAT WERE REALLY REALLY
TERRIBLY GRADED SO YEAH HUGE
SLOPES THINGS LIKE THAT THINGS
THAT WOULD MAKE DEVELOPMENTS
MORE EXPENSIVE. OR LESS LIKELY
TO OCCUR. FOR THE MOST PART
THIS WAS A PRETTY BIG BROAD
GRAB. AFTER THAT PIECE WAS DONE
AND CONCURRENT TO THE INVENTORY
TGS HD WERE DEVELOPING A
SCREENING TOOL. THAT SCREENING
TOOL IN THERE'S A SLIGHT ON IT
COMING UP WAS NOT MEANT TO
ELIMINATE THE PARCELS SO MUCH
AS IT WAS STUCK TO HELP US KIND
OF PRIORITIZE THEM. AND I
UNDERSTAND WHERE HOUSING MIGHT
BE MORE OR LESS VIABLE. FOR
PICK ASIDE OVER AGAINST ANOTHER
ONE. AFTER THAT WAS DONE THE
NEXT BIG STEP AND THE MOST
DAUNTING I THINK WAS THE
DEPARTMENTAL BETTING SO WHAT
THAT MEANS IS. IN A WEEK WE
LOOK AT A SITE AND WE HAVE A
PIECE OF PROPERTY THAT LOOKS
LIKE IT'S EMINENTLY DEVELOP
HOLE. WE'VE SCREENED IT'S AND
IT MEETS A LOT OF THE FACTORS
THAT YOU WOULD EXPECT TO SEE A
GOOD AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT TO NEED TO HAVE IN
ORDER TO BE DEVELOPED. BUT WE
TALK TO THE DEPARTMENT
ULTIMATELY ABOUT IT. WE NEED TO
ASK WHETHER OR NOT THAT SITE
HAD ANY SORT OF ENCUMBRANCES
THAT WOULD PRECLUDE
DEVELOPMENT. MAYBE OVER THE
LAST THIRTY YEARS THERE HAVE
BEEN YOU KNOW. A LONG TERM
EASEMENTS GRANTED TO PRIVATE
SECTOR ENTITIES THE LOCALS. TO
RUN UTILITIES THROUGHOUT THEIR
THAT WOULD BE REALLY EXPENSIVE
TO MOVE OR MAYBE. THE PROPERTY
HAS A MEDIATION ISSUES OR MAYBE
THE PROPERTY WAS A SHE TO THE
STATE TWENTY FIVE YEARS AGO FOR
A VERY SPECIFIC PURPOSE. AND
WOULD REQUIRE A CHANGE IN
STATUTE TO. ALTER ITS USE. WE
DIDN'T KNOW THOSE THINGS
INITIAL INVENTORY AND SO ALL
THE SITES THAT WE THEN.
IDENTIFIED AS PART OF THAT
THIRTEEN AND THIRTY PARCELS
WHERE THAN VETTED WITH
APARTMENTS. FROM THERE. WE GOT
DOWN TO A SMALLER NUMBER OF
SITES THAT DEPARTMENTS HAVE
SAID YES WE AGREE. THIS COULD
OR SHOULD BE DECLARED ACCESS WE
NO LONGER NEEDED THERE ARE
KNOWN CONFERENCES ON THE SITE
THAT WOULD PRECLUDE
DEVELOPMENT. WE ARE FINE WITH
THESE BEING DECLARED ACCESSING
GOING THROUGH. THE REST OF
EXECUTIVE ORDER PROCESS I
SHOULD SHOULD KNOW THEIR- JUST
A SEC OF POSTERITY THAT WHEN WE
DO POLICY SITES. I'M SURE SURE
THERE'S GOING TO BE A SITE OR
TWO OR SEVEN. EACH OF YOUR
DISTRICTS THAT WHERE YOU'RE CAN
BE CONFUSED AS TO WHY IT'S NOT
ON THE LIST BECAUSE YOU. ABSENT
SURE THAT IT WASN'T UTILIZED
APPROPRIATELY OR WHATEVER ELSE
THE CASE MAY BE. THERE ARE
THERE ARE THOSE AND WE'LL TALK
ABOUT HOW WE KIND OF WANNA
WELCOME THAT FEEDBACK COMING
SOON. BUT THE SIMPLE IN TIME
YOU KNOW THERE'S A THERE'S
APPEALS PROCESS WHICH ARE GOING
TO DEPARTMENTS OR SOMETHING
THAT WILL OBVIOUSLY BE GOING
AND WORKING WITH THEM ON AND
CHALLENGING A LITTLE BIT BUT-
FOR THE MOST PART THE SITES
THAT WE'RE GONNA TALK ABOUT
RELEASED THE INVENTORY WE HAVE.
ARE BASED ON ALL OF THOSE
INITIAL YESES AGAIN WE'RE KIND
OF FOCUSING ON SPEED WHAT WE
CAN GET OUT FIRST. WHILE WE
LOOK AT A MEDIUM AND LONG TERM.
ROLL OUT PLAN. SO AFTER BERMAN
VETTING WHICH IS DONE. THE NEXT
TWO BIG STEPS FOR US WERE SITE
PRIVATIZATION AND DEVELOPMENT
OF A HEAT MAP. THE EXECUTIVE
ORDER ULTIMATELY CALLS FOR THE
PUBLICATION OF A MAP THAT SHOWS
THE AVAILABLE ACCESS SITES.
SUPERIMPOSED WITH A MAP THAT
SHOWS WHERE HOUSING IS
GENERALLY NEEDED. SO AGAIN
GOING BACK TO THAT AND DIAGRAM
YOU COULD SAY. HERE'S NAPA
COUNTY HERE THE- FAX NUMBER OF
SITES AVAILABLE NAPA COUNTY.
AND HERE'S THOSE PORTIONS NAPA
COUNTY WHERE. HOUSING IS NEEDED
IN PLACES WHERE IT'S NEED LESS.
SO BE A QUICK EASY VISUAL FOR
GOING TO KIND OF SEE AND
HOPEFULLY. YOU KNOW A CHECK ON
US AS TO WHERE WE'RE GONNA
PRIORITIZE. DEVELOPMENTS THE
PUBLICATION. OF THE HEAT MAP.
IS FORTHCOMING. AND THEN AT
THAT POINT. WHAT KIND OF
CONCURRENT TO IT WE NEED TO DO
A NUMBER OF REALISTIC TO
DILIGENCE STEPS SO RATHER THAN
ISSUE ARE PEAS SORT OF SIGHT
UNSEEN WE- ASKED FOR AND
RECEIVED FUNDING IN THE LAST
BUDGET CYCLE. TO DO SORT OF
PREDELLA WORK SO WE WOULD BE
HIRING A REALISTIC CONSULTANT
TO COME OUT AND DO AN ECONOMIC
ANALYSIS ON A MITCHELL SITES.
HELP MAKE SURE THERE ARE PEAS
ARE TAILORED TO THE PARTICULAR
DOUBLE ABILITY OF A PARTICULAR
SITE WE ALSO WANT TO DO LIKE A
FIRE ENVIRONMENTAL ASSESSMENT
PHASE ONE ASSESSMENT. THE
MANAGER TECHNICAL TESTING PULL
TYLER POURED VALIDATE THAT THE
PROPERTY BOUNDARIES THINGS LIKE
THAT SO THAT WE KNOW TO WORRY
REDUCE THE LIKELIHOOD OF DOING
IN OUR P. FINDING. SOMETHING
THAT WOULD DEVELOP. MAKE SURE
THAT WE GO OUT WITH HIS HAS
TEED UP AS POSSIBLE FOR
DEVELOPERS TO. BUILD AND THEN
OF COURSE THE FINAL STEP IN THE
PROCESS IS THE ISSUE INSOFAR AS
PEACE. TO REALLY WE ARE. YOU
KNOW VERY VERY CLOSE TO THE
PUBLICATION HEAT MAP AND THE
LAST TWO STEPS. THE REALISTIC
YOU DILIGENCE AND THE ACTIONS
OF THEIR FEES ARE WE HAVE IN
FRONT OF US. THE SEPTEMBER
DEADLINE THAT WAS MENTIONED
EARLIER WITH THERE IS A
DEADLINE AN EXECUTIVE ORDER TO
ISSUE AT LEAST THE FIRST. SET
OF OUR PEAS BY THE END OF
SEPTEMBER. WE ARE ON TRACK TO
DO THAT AGAIN THIS IS GONNA RUN
WAVES THIS IS NOT GOING TO BE
YOU KNOW. TWO HUNDRED OUR KEYS
AT ONCE IT'S GOING TO BE SOME
NUMBER OF THEM WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE LOVED.
LEARNING OUR LESSONS
EFFECTIVELY WE WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT AS WE GET OUR PEACE OUT
AND WE GET RESPONSES. THINGS
ARE GONNA GO RIGHT THINGS ARE
GONNA GO WRONG WE WANNA LEARN
FROM THOSE AS OPPOSED TO DOING
A MASSIVE WAVE OF THINGS. AND
KIND OF. FINDING OUT THERE SOME
FATAL FLAW IN THEM. THE OTHER
ELEMENT TO I THINK IS IMPORTANT
IS ALSO LIMITED STAFF TO PASS
SITTING SO WHERE CONNECTING TO
DO THAT. AS WELL JUDICIOUSLY.
SO OUR INVENTORY. 440-003-0070
PARCELLS AGAIN VISUAL REVIEW WE
LOOKED AT GRADING UTILIZATION.
ADJACENT SEES AGAIN IS AN EXTRA
RESIDENTIAL IS THERE APPEAR TO
BE. AMENITIES THAT WOULD BE
SUPPORTIVE OF HOUSING. AGAIN IN
A PRETTY BROAD VERY LITTLE
SENSE. WE DID ALSO LOOK AT
ALTERNATE DEVELOPMENT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE MOST PART
AND WE FLAG SOME PROPERTIES
THAT ARE ON THE BORDERLINE WE
ALSO LOOKED AT PROPERTIES THAT
HAD SOME DEGREE OF UTILIZATION.
BUT WE'RE BOB OWNED BUT OR BY
OPERATED BY DEPARTMENTS WHO
HAVE A HISTORY OF TURNING
PROPERTIES OVER SO YOU SEE AGE
PETER DMV'S MAKING SURE THAT
THOSE SITES FOR LOOK AT PRETTY
HARD. THAT DID GET DOWN TO
ABOUT THIRTEEN HER THIRTY
PARCELS WE THEN STOPPED USING
THE PARCEL DOCUMENT DESIGNATION
WE START LOOKING AT SITES SO
FOR EXAMPLE. CAPITOL PARK HERE
THIS IS NOT ONE PIECE OF
PROPERTY FROM AND L. INTENT
THAN FIFTEEN THAT'S MADE UP OF
MORTAL PARCELS. AND SO RATHER
THAN KIND OF TALKING THIS
PARCEL DEMARCATION AND GETTING
FOLKS MAYBE MISLEADING AS TO
HOW MANY PROPERTIES ARE OUT
THERE WE STARTED SAYING LET'S
LET'S GROUP THESE THINGS
TOGETHER IN TERMS OF WHAT WILL
BE ACTUALLY DOUBLE DOUBLE. AS
WE STARTED USING SITES AS THE
TERM THOSE THIRTEEN AND THIRTY
PARCELS NATURALLY COALESCED
INTO ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY SITES. AND THEN WE WENT
THROUGH THE DEPARTMENT OF
VETTING PROCESS AND RIGHT NOW
WE'RE SITTING IN A ABOUT A
HUNDRED SITES. THAT HAD GOTTEN
YES IS NO WHICH IS THAT'S A
HUNDRED MORE THAN HE STARTED
WITH WHICH IS FANTASTIC. THAT
NUMBER'S GONNA FLUCTUATES AND I
CAN ALMOST PROMISE THAT IT'S
GONNA FLUCTUATE BECAUSE OF SOME
THOSE APPEALS I MENTIONED IT'S
GOING TO FLUCTUATE BECAUSE- WE
ARE ALSO KINDA DOING OVERLAYS
OF. YOU STATE HAZARD MAPS AND
THINGS LIKE THAT IT'S GOING TO
FLUCTUATE BECAUSE OF. LOCAL TO
ENTITIES COMING FOR WITH DEALS
THAT WE HADN'T CONSIDERED
BEFORE YOU KNOW FOR EXAMPLE. I
WAS WHICH COUNTY IT WAS BUT
THERE WAS ONE COUNTY WHO. WE
HAD ACTUALLY EXCLUDED A SITE IN
OUR INITIAL INVENTORY IT WAS IN
ITSELF COMPLETELY NOT
APPROPRIATE FOR HOUSING IT WAS
WAY OUT IN THE WOODS. BUT THEY
WANTED TO USE IT FOR AN
ALTERNATE PURPOSE AND THEY'RE
WILLING TO DO A LAND SWAP
BETWEEN THAT PROPERTY AND A
DECENT SURVEY CREATURES THAT
WAS RESIDENTIALLY LOCATED. AND
SO YOU KNOW THOSE SORTS OF
DEALS AND THINGS ARE GONNA MAKE
THIS NUMBER FLUCTUATES
ESPECIALLY IF WE PUBLISH THE
MAP. BUT IT'S GOT KIND OF WORK
SITTING AT PRESENT THIS MAP IS
NAPA COUNTY AND IT GIVES YOU A
SENSE FOR ALL OF THE PROPERTY
TO THE STATE OWNED IN THE
COUNTY. YOU'LL NOTICE SOME
PARTICULAR CLUSTERING YOU ALSO
NOTICE YOU KNOW JUST SORT OF
THOSE WITH NO THE COUNTY HOW.
IF THE RESERVES ARE PRETTY
RURAL AREAS IN SOME CASES THESE
ARE MORE URBAN THIS IS THIS IS
A SNAPSHOT CAM WE WENT THROUGH
WE WERE DEVELOPING THE THIS
INVENTORY. THIS NEXT SLIDE IS
AN EXAMPLE OF A SITE THAT IS
GOING TO BE ON THE US LIST AND
WE WOULD SEE ESPECIALLY BIBLE
FOR DEVELOPMENT. YOU'LL NOTICE
IT'S ACTUALLY THE PARK AREA TO
THE NORTH IS THE CAPITAL SO IT
IS JUST TO THE SOUTH A COUPLE
HERE. HERE IN SACRAMENTO IT'S A
DTS OWN SITE ACTUALLY. TRY TO
BE POTENTIALLY GO FORWARD AS A
DEVELOPMENT. BUT IT'S NOT A
BIG. FORTY ACRE SITE IN THE
MIDDLE OF AN URBAN AREA IT'S
SMALLER SITE. THE EXECUTIVE
ORDER DOES CALL OUT BIG
DEVELOPMENTS IN A CALLS OUT
SMALL DEVELOPMENTS THIS MIGHT
BE A FORTY MICRO UNIT SITES.
THAT COULD BE A DIVERSE AND
AFFORDABLE WERE LOOKING AT
EVERYTHING UNDER THE SUN AND
NOT. PUTTING OURSELVES JUST TO
YOU KNOW THE BIG STUFF. SO I'M
SURE YOU WANT TO KNOW KIND OF
HOW WE SCREEN THE SITES AND FOR
THAT SUCH AS GOING TO KIND OF
WALK ADDRESS. IT MORNING YES.
PLEASE INTRODUCE FOR YOU KNOW
HE'S YOUR GOOD JASON KENNEY
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF REAL ESTATE
SERVICES DIVISION DEPARTMENT OF
GENERAL SERVICES THANK YOU FOR
THAT REPORT AND WE HAVE SASHA
WOOD WITH SAKE THE DATA
RESEARCH MANAGER FOR HOUSING-POLICY AT DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING
COMMITTEE DEVELOPMENT THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING SAYS JASON DESCRIBED
IT'S BEEN A PRETTY RAPID
PROCESS SINCE THE GOVERNOR
SIGNED THE EXECUTIVE ORDER AND
AS WE DEVELOP SCREENING
CRITERIA DECENT ALLUDED TO THIS
BUT WE WERE BOTH TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT WHERE HOUSING IS
MOST NEEDED. AND WORST
PARTICULAR SITES MIGHT BE MORE
ECONOMICALLY FEASIBLE THAN
OTHERS AGAIN EMPHASIZING WHAT
JASON SAID WE WEREN'T SAYING NO
TO SITES BUT JUST TRYING TO
IDENTIFY WHAT OUR PRIORITIES
MIGHT BE GIVEN THESE FACTORS SO
IN THIS VITAL TALK THROUGH.
BOTH THE HOUSING NEED CRITERIA
AND THE ECONOMIC FEASIBILITY.
SO WE THREE MEASURES TO
IDENTIFY WHERE HOUSING IS MOST
NEEDED AND IMPACTFUL AND
ACTUALLY RIFFS ON SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT SENATOR DODD
MENTIONED AT THE START IN THE
INTRODUCTION. SO ALL COVER
THOSE NOW. THE FIRST THE
AVAILABILITY OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. AND THAT'S ADDRESSING
THE AVAILABILITY OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IN THE JOB AND
COMMUTERS SHEDS TO REALLY
TRYING TO ADDRESS THOSE
HOUSEHOLDS THAT MAY NOT BE ABLE
TO FIND. HOMES THAT ARE CLOSE
TO WHERE THEY'RE WORKING. TO
MEASURE THAT WE LOOK AT WHERE
THE SHORTFALL IN UNITS THAT ARE
RENTED AT A LEVEL AFFORDABLE TO
VERY LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS. ART
IS GREATER THAN 30% OF THE
NUMBER OF FEEL I HOUSE OF
NUMBER OF VERY LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS EXCUSE ME. TO REALLY
TRYING TO LOOK AT WHERE THERE'S
A GAP BETWEEN AVAILABLE HOUSING
FOR FOLKS THAT REALLY NEED IT.
WHO ARE WORKING UBER HOODS AND
WHERE DOES NOT EXIST. THAT
MEASURE ALONG WITH EVERYTHING
ELSE IS PUBLICLY AVAILABLE DATA
SO WE'RE NOT TRYING TO USE
PROPRIETARY DATA HERE. WE ALSO
LOOK AT THE GAP BETWEEN SUPPLY
AND DEMAND AND SPECIFICALLY
WHERE THE GAP BETWEEN THE
REGIONAL HOUSING NEEDS
ASSESSMENT OR THE RINA. AND
BUILDING PERMITS ISSUED WHERE
THAT GAP IS GREATER THAN
FIFTEEN HUNDRED PERMITS SO
WHERE THE JURISDICTION IS NOT
PRODUCING. UP TO THEIR PLANNING
GOALS. AND THIRD WE ALSO LOOK
AT THE RATE OF INCREASE AND
RENTS. SPECIFICALLY WHERE THE
MEDIAN GROSS RENT INCREASED BY
MORE THAN 5% IN A YEAR OVER
YEAR BASIS SO RULING LOOKING AT
WHERE THERE'S- ACTIVE PRESSURE.
IN THE RENTAL MARKET AND
AFFORDABILITY IS DIMINISHING.
TO LOOK AT SPECIFIC SITES WE-
ALSO EXAMINE ECONOMIC
FEASIBILITY MEASURES AND HERE
WE USE SEVERAL MEASURES TO
EVALUATED DEFERRED AT THE
DEVELOPMENT PROJECT WOULD BE
FEASIBLE. AND NAMELY WE BUILD
ON THAT TGS ANALYSIS THAT
DECENT DESCRIBED AT THE START
SO BEFORE WE EVEN GET TO
THINKING ABOUT WHAT TYPES OF
ECONOMIC FEASIBILITY THERE MAY
BE IF A SITE IS GRADED
VERTICALLY WE KNOW IT WILL BE
VERY EXPENSIVE IF NOT IT
IMPOSSIBLE TO DEVELOP THEIR SO
IN THAT WAY OUR ECONOMIC
FEASIBILITY MODEL REALLY BUILT
OFF OF THE ANALYSIS THAT
JASON'S TEAM LEAD. FURTHER WE
LOOK AT PROXIMITY TO JOB
CENTERS THREE LOOKING AT CENSUS
TRACKS WHERE THE NUMBER OF JOBS
THAT ARE AVAILABLE TO PEOPLE
WITH LESS THAN A BE A- BOMB AND
THAT FALL WITHIN A GIVEN
RADIUS. ARE NOT REALLY MEETING
THE NEEDS OF THOSE FOLKS THAT
ARE WORKING THERE. TO DO THIS
WE USE THAT EACH CITY ANTI CáC
OPPORTUNITY MAPS AND WE'RE
LOOKING AT THE TOP TWO
QUINTILES. WE ALSO LOOK AT
PROXIMITY THE EDUCATION. AGAIN
MENTIONING SOME OF THE FACTORS
THAT YOU DESCRIBED. WE LOOK AT
CENSUS TRACKS FOR THE EDUCATION
COMPOSITE INDICATOR IS WITHIN
THE TOP TWO QUINTILES STATEWIDE
SO MAKING SURE THAT IF. THESE
SITES ARE IN AREAS OF
OPPORTUNITY THERE'S ALSO GOING
TO BE HI OPPORTUNITY EDUCATION
I'M THERE FOR THE HOUSEHOLDS.
WE ALSO LOOK AT PROXIMITY TO
HIGH FREQUENCY PUBLIC TRANSIT.
AND ANY AREA WITHIN THE STATE
THAT IS WITHIN HALF A MILE OF
HIGH FREQUENCY PUBLIC TRANSIT
STOPS. SO WITH THOSE FACTORS WE
CAN THEN START TO MEASURE HOW
EACH ONE OF THE SITES ARE
STACKING UP. AND A SITE MAY BE
IN AN AREA WITH HIGH HOUSING
NEED OR MODERATE HOUSING NEED.
AT A PARTICULAR SITE MAY BE
HITTING ON EACH ONE OF THOSE
THREE ECONOMIC FEASIBILITY
FACTORSWERE NINE. AGAIN NOT TO
BE SCRIPT PRESCRIPTIVE BUT JUST
TO SHOW THAT THESE SITES IF
THEY'RE MEETING ON THOSE
ECONOMIC FEASIBILITY FACTORS.
THEY MAY BE MORE COMPETITIVE
FOR TAX CREDITS AND OTHER A
FIND AFFORDABLE HOUSING FINANCE
THAT'S AVAILABLE. AWESOME TWO
IN TERMS OF THE DEVELOPMENT
APPROACH. THE FIRST BILL POINT
STATE DEVELOPMENTS BUT I THINK
IT'S A GOOD TIME TO KIND OF
HIGHLIGHT THE WAY THIS IS BEING
APPROACH TYPICALLY WITH THE
LOCALS AT THE END THE DAY WE
FOUND THE TICKET MORE TAXES
WITH COMING UP WITH IN TOURING
THAT INVENTORY IS DONE IT'LL BE
PUBLISHED AND WHAT THAT REALLY
SHOWS IS THESE ARE THE SITES
THE STATUS SAID. WE COULD SEE
DEVELOP AS HOUSING IT DOESN'T
NECESSARILY MEAN THAT EVERY
SINGLE ON THE SITES ARE YOU
KNOW THE BILL POLL IT MAY BE
THAT THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT
LOCAL CONCERNS IT MAY BE THAT
THERE ARE THINGS THAT MAKE THEM
MORE OR LESS DIFFICULT TO
DEVELOPE THAT WE'RE NOT AWARE
OF STILL THE LOCAL LEVEL IT MAY
BE THAT ALL THE SITES ARE GOOD
BUT THERE ARE SOME SITES THAT
ARE BETTER OR WORSE THAN OTHERS.
THE NUMBER OF PLACES WHERE I
THINK. NICE THAT OUR LIST AS A
GOES OUT IS REALLY SORT OF
STATE INVENTORY PROPERTY AND
THEN THE NEXT SET OF THIS
REALLY BIG IS WORKING LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO IDENTIFY WHERE
WE SHOULD BE PRIORITIZING
DEVELOPMENTS OBVIOUSLY WORKED
BECAUSE THE COMMITTED LINE
THERE'S GONNA BE SOME
PRIVATIZATION IS HAPPENING
EARLY ON AND WHERE WE ARE WE
ARE WORKING WITH LOCALS ON THAT
BUT ONCE NOT GOES PUBLIC I
THINK THAT'S WHEN WE EXPECT THE
MORE VOLUMINOUS CONVERSATIONS
TO HAPPEN ABOUT PARTICULAR.
SITES PARTICULAR LIABILITIES
PARTICULAR USES. SO FAR
THROUGHOUT THIS PROCESS THERE
HAVE BEEN QUITE A FEW LOCAL
ENTITIES CITY AND COUNTY LEVEL.
AS WELL AS PROFESSIONAL
ORGANIZATIONS WHO REACHED OUT
SOME OF COME THROUGH MEMBERS
SOME OF COME THROUGH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE SOME COME
THROUGH CONSULTANT SOME OF COME
TO US DIRECTLY. AND WE'VE WE'VE
HAD THE SAME MESSAGE TO ALL OF
THEM ALL THE MAP IS COMING IF
YOU'VE GOT SITES HERE WHERE OF
PLEASE LET US KNOW. AS ENTITIES
HAVE PROPOSED SITES WITH
ACTUALLY EVEN IF WE'VE SCREEN
THEM OUT WE ADDED THEM TO LIST
AND WENT TO THE APARTMENTS
INVENTED OUR GOAL. STATE AND WE
FIND THAT THE LOCAL INPUT THAT
PROCESS IS GOING TO BE
INVALUABLE. AT THE SAME POINT
TIME EVEN THOUGH THE OUR STATE
DEVELOPMENTS THERE STILL AN
ABSOLUTE LOCAL CONNECTIVITY
THAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN YOU AT A
MINIMUM WATER SEWER GAS THINGS-LIKE THAT AND SO. YOU KNOW THE
PARTNERSHIP WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS CAN BE CRITICAL WE
ALSO AGREED RECOGNIZE THAT WE
ARE IN A DEARTH OF LOCAL
INFORMATION KEEPING WITH LOCAL
AGAIN HOPEFULLY. STOCK TO
REPETITIVE BUT WE RECOGNIZE
THAT WE DON'T KNOW NECESSARILY
THAT TINA TWO BLOCKS DOWN THE
STREET THERE WAS A DEVELOPMENT
THAT WAS PLAN PROPOSED IN IT.
IT FIT DIETER FAILED FOR
REASONS ACT WIRES THE THOSE
LESSONS LEARNED HOW TO AVOID
THOSE ISSUES WEEK WE RECOGNIZE
WE DON'T KNOW THAT AND- YOU
KNOW PICK UP PICK A RANDOM
STREET AND ANY PICKLER YOU KNOW
JURISDICTION IN THE STATE SO. I
THINK THOSE CONVERSATIONS AND
THOSE LESSONS LEARNED ARE GOING
TO BE ABSOLUTELY INVALUABLE AND
WE- EXECUTIVE ORDER HIGHLIGHTS
AND WE ARE EXPECTING TO. HAVE A
ROBUST. PARTNERSHIP LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS YOU KNOW ONCE THE
ONCE THE MAP GOES OUT. THAT
SAID THE APPROACH IN THE
EXECUTIVE ORDERS PRETTY SIMPLE
YOU KNOW ASIDE FROM LEVERAGING
EXISTING SURPLUS PROPERTY.
WHICH I'LL TALK ABOUT IN LAST
LIED WE WILL BE FOCUSING ON
LONG TERM GROUND LEASES. WE
HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO ENTER
INTO LEASES UP TO UP QUITE A
LONG TERM WE CAN GO NINE NINE
YEARS HE WANTED TO. WAIVERS CAN
BE BEST ALTERNATELY FOR THAT
DEVELOPMENT AND BY ABILITY WE
CAN LEVERAGE STATE PROPERTY
VALUES WE DO NOT HAVE TO LISA
FOR MARKET VALUE FOR THE
PROPERTY ITSELF. IN THAT WAY WE
CAN WE CONTRIVE THE- POTENTIAL
FOR DEVELOPMENT. PLEASE GIVE
ORDER DOES CALL OUT IN A BIT OF
CONSTRUCTION SO AGAIN THESE ARE
NOT YOUR TYPICAL DEVELOPMENTS
WITH A DIESEL HAVE TO BE. WELL
THAT'S MASS TIMBER MODULAR
UNITS PREFABRICATION MICRO
UNITS WE'RE LOOKING AT AS MANY
INNOVATIVE WAYS TO BUILD
HOUSING AS POSSIBLE. THERE'S
ALSO HIGHLIGHTS EXECUTIVE ORDER
BY DOING THIS IN A VERY
SUSTAINABLE WAY AND COST
EFFECTIVELY SUSTAINABLE WAY.
AND THEN DOING IT IN AN
EQUITABLE WAY WHETHER THAT'S
FAILING WAGE OR ARE FOCUSING ON
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AS WELL.
AND THEN FINALLY I THINK A
COUPLE OTHER HIGHLIGHTS THAT
WITH MENTIONING. THE SECOND
ORDER ALSO DOES CALL OUT LAND
SWAPS I MENTION ONE EXAMPLE
EARLIER. AND THERE'S LIMITED.
EXISTING AUTHORITY TO THAT BUT
WHERE POSSIBLE WE'RE ALSO
LOOKING AT. ROLE OF MAYBE OUR
SITE IS IN GREAT FOR HOUSING.
BE GREAT FOR SOME ALTERNATE USE
IF THE CITY OR COUNTY HAD A- SO
WE COULD SWAP AND ONE GOES
HOUSING ONE GOES WHERE THEY
ALTERNATE USES WERE OPEN TO
THOSE TYPES OF ARRANGEMENTS AS
WELL. WERE ALSO OPEN TO CO
DEVELOPMENTS ONE PARTICULAR
CITY REACHED OUT DURING THE
PROCESS THERE WAS A PARTIAL
THAT WE HAD THAT WAS VERY
IRREGULAR SHAPED IT REALLY
WOULD NOT HAVE WORKED FOR
HOUSING HOWEVER THEY OWN THE
TWO ADJACENT PARCELS AND AS A
CODE DEVELOPMENT IT'S- ACTUALLY
VERY VERY VIABLE. AND SO
LOOKING AT THOSE CONVERSATIONS
WITH A LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AS
WELL WE'VE BEEN VERY PLEASED TO
KIND OF SEE SOME VERY
INNOVATIVE IDEAS. SECOND TO
LAST EXISTING SURPLUS SO ONE OF
THE CHALLENGES HISTORICALLY
WITH US A PROPERTY IS. AFTER
DECLARE SURPLUS IN SOME CASES
PROPERTY SETS. IT'S FOR NUMBER
OF REASONS. BUT IN SOME CASES
IT'S BECAUSE OF POTENTIAL STATE
WE USE AND. BALLOTS THAT'S A
BIG REASON WHY AND SO THE
EXECUTIVE ORDER THE VETTING
PROCESS THERE WERE QUITE A FEW
DEPARTMENTS WOULD PROPERTIES
WHO HAD BEEN YOU KNOW
VACILLATING ON POTENTIALLY
REDUCE THEIR PROPERTY THE
FUTUREWHO SAID NO WE'RE FINE
WITH ALTERNATELY DIVESTING OF
THIS AND SO THERE ARE SOME
SIGNIFICANT SURPLUS PROPERTIES
ACROSS THE STATE THAT HAVE
BEEN. SHAKEN LOOSE AS WELL
THROUGHOUT THIS AND I THINK THE
LAST POINT IS THE OTHERS
THERE'S A MENTION EXECUTIVE
ORDER ON YOU'RE PRIORITIZING
FUNDING AS WELL FOR THE EFFORT
SO I THINK ALL OF OUR- YOU KNOW
THE IF THE AUTHORITIES ARE
THERE THE WILLINGNESS IS THERE
AT THE DEPARTMENTS HAVE BEEN
GREAT AND GIVING UP. PROPERTIES
THAT THEY DO NOT NEED ANYMORE
SO FAR ARE ENGAGING WITH THE
LOCALS HAVE BEEN HAVE BEEN
REALLY ENCOURAGING AND
REFRESHING AND WERE ABOUT THAT.
STAGE WILL PUBLISH THE MAP AND
BEGIN THE ACTUAL ART PIECE. SO
THAT WAS A LOT I KNOW SHE GOT
QUESTIONS. AND THEN WE CAN
ANSWER FOR YOU GUYS. PROCEED TO
REPORT ANY QUESTIONS FIRST
CENTER BRADFORD FIRST AND I
APOLOGIZE MISTER KING I WAS IN
AND OUT DURING YOUR
PRESENTATION BUT DID YOU SAY AT
WHAT POINT WOULD YOU HAVE ALL
THE SITES IDENTIFIED IN THE MAP
FINALIZED THE HEAT MAP RELEASE
WE HAD SAID A FEW MONTHS BACK
COULD BE THE SUMMER OF TWENTY
NINETEEN. SO WE EXPECTED BE
FAIRLY IMMINENT OKAY. SENATE
NIELSEN AND IS THERE A FOCUSED
ON. HOUSING TO BE AVAILABLE
THEN FOR THE HOMELESS OR THIS
JUST IN GENERAL HOUSING PERIOD
FOR ANYBODY WE ARE LOOKING AT
HOUSING MORE IN GENERAL AT ALL
RANGES FROM VERY LOW
AFFORDABILITY ALL WITH THE WORK
FORCE IT'S IT REALLY WILL
DEPEND ON THE AREA AND THE
SITES AND WHAT THE BIBLE BUT-
WE'RE NOT. NECESSARILY SHUTTING
OFF ANY THE DOORS. HOW ABOUT IN
HIGH COST COUNTIES LIKE MARIN
FOR EXAMPLE. WHAT CAN WE DO IN
A COUNTY THAT HIGH COST SO
LET'S THAT GOES BACK TO
LEVERAGING STATE PROPERTY
VALUES YOU KNOW WE'VE GOT WE'VE
GOT PROPERTY IN SOME AREAS THAT
SELLS FOR THREE MILLION DOLLARS
AN ACRE AND SO BEING ABLE TO
LEVERAGE A LONG TERM LEASE
MAYBE FIFTY YEARS FOR A DOLLAR
AND BEING ABLE TO DRIVE DOWN
THE COST FOR CONSTRUCTION THERE
IS A HUGE WIN WE CAN CONTRIBUTE
TO THE AFFORDABLE. DEVELOPMENT.
WELL ONE OF THE ISSUE.
OBVIOUSLY HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS
HAVE TO FACTOR INTO THIS
BECAUSE WE'RE LOOKING FOR
HOUSING FOR CALIFORNIANS WHO
NEED HOUSING. AND AS TO THE
COST OF HOUSING. THERE ARE MANY
DRIVING FACTORS BUT HAVE YOU
LOOKED AT ANY OF THOSE DRIVING
FACTORS AND THINGS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE CAN DO TO. HOLD
BACKSOME OF THE COST FACTORS
THAT HAVE BEEN DRIVEN BY
VARIOUS THINGS STATE POLICY.
LOCAL POLICY PLANNING AT CENTER.
EXECUTIVE ORDER HAS US WORKING
LARGELY WITHIN THE FRAMEWORK OF
EXISTING STATUTE THE WAY IT WAS
WRITTEN EMPHASIZES ALTERNATE
DEVELOPMENTS THAT CAN BE
CHEAPER WHETHER THAT SUCH TINY
HOW DEVELOPMENTS A SHIPPING
CONTAINER DEVELOPMENT USING UP
OTHER FORMS OF PRE FAB OR OR
MODULAR CONSTRUCTION. TIMBER
ACTUALLY CAN BE FOR LEGAL CLUB
ON EXPENSIVE EXPENSIVE TO BUILD
SO WE HAVE LOOKED AT WAYS
WITHIN THE EXISTING FRAMEWORK
OF PURSUING MORE COST EFFECTIVE
HOUSING BUT NOW WE HAVEN'T.
SILLY PROPOSE ANYTHING THAT
WOULD CHANGE THAT FRAMEWORK.
AND I JUST OFFER THAT BEING
ABLE TO DISCOUNT THE LAND VALUE
AND ENDS UP BEING A HUGE DRIVER
AND MAKING AFFORDABLE HOUSING
POSSIBLE AND FEASIBLE. IN HIGH
COST AREAS AND WHILE THIS WOULD
BE A NEW ENDEAVOR FOR THE STATE
IT'S A VERY COMMON ENDEAVOR FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FINANCE TO
HAVE PUBLIC AGENCIES. BY THE
LOW COST LONG TERM GROUND
LEASES AND SERVING ALMOST AS
FIRST IN ACQUISITION FUNDING.
AND SO IN THIS WAY THE STATUS
SETTING AN EXAMPLE AND ALSO
FOLLOWING I'M PRETTY
ESTABLISHED PRACTICE IN THIS
REGARD. FOCUSED JUST ON STATE
PROPERTIES HAVE YOU LOOKED INTO
NO PRIVATE NON PROFITS THAT
HAVE DONE THINGS. CALIFORNIAN
THE DEVELOPMENT CORPORATION FOR
EXAMPLE IN. MAHAL PIES AND
DIFFERENT THINGS LIKE THAT OR
IS THAT A PART OF YOUR
INVENTORY OR NOT. ARMENDARIZ
FOCUS THE LANDS THAT WE THE
STATE OWNS AND CONTROLS WE HAVE
THAT WE HAVE HAD CONVERSATIONS
WITH SOME NONPROFIT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPERS IN TERMS OF
APPROACH XIN YOU KNOW CONCEPT%
AND THINGS LIKE THAT WE FULLY
EXPECT ONCE THE MAP GOES PUBLIC
THAT THERE WILL BE THOSE SORTS
OF CONVERSATIONS THAT HAPPENED.
WE WOULD WELCOME THOSE
CONVERSATIONS HAPPENING BUT
RIGHT NOW OUR FOCUS HAS BEEN
THAT THE PROPERTY THAT THE
STATE OWNS WELL I WOULD SUGGEST
IT BE WELL TO TAKE A LOOK. AT
THE NATURE OF THE TO THE-
ELATION YOU'RE GOING TO TRY TO
PROVIDE IT FOR. AND IF WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT CHALLENGED
POPULATIONS. FOR EXAMPLE
HOMELESS HARD CORE LONG TERM
HOMELESS. WE'RE GLAD TO LOOK A
HOUSING IN AREAS WHERE THERE
ARE WOULD BE RESOURCES TO SERVE
THAT POPULATION. LIKE
REHABILITATIVE RESOURCES FOR
THEM. THAT THERE WOULD BE
GAINFUL EMPLOYMENT THAT THERE
WOULD BE CAREER TECH.
OPPORTUNITIES ARE THOSE FACTORS
THAT YOU CONSIDER TO BE ABLE TO
THE EXTENT THAT WERE YOU KNOW
LOOKING AT SITE FEASIBILITY AND
LOOKING AT ECONOMIC FEASIBILITY
WE ARE LOOKING FOR THE
AVAILABILITY OF JOBS THAT FOLKS
WITH LESS THAN A BACHELOR'S
DEGREE COULD PERCEIVE SO WE'RE
NOT ONLY LOOKING FOR YOU KNOW.
HI I'M COME EARNING JOBS BUT
FOR A RANGE AND WE'RE LOOKING
TO WHERE THERE'S TREMENDOUS
NEED WHERE THERE'S NOT ENOUGH
HOUSING FOR PEOPLE THAT ALREADY
HAVE JOBS IN THIS HIGH COST
AREAS SO WE'RE WE'RE DOING THAT
THROUGH THE SITE ANALYSIS AND
THEN IT ALSO SEE THAT THROUGH
THE REAL ESTATE CONSULTANT
WORKING THROUGH OUR PROPERTY
DUE DILIGENCE WILL BE DOING
TRADITIONAL THINGS THAT ANY
REAL ESTATE DEVELOPER WOULD BE
DOING. INCLUDING A MARKET
ANALYSIS NEVER CONSIDERING
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT WE WOULD
ALSO BE DOING A SCANNED FOR THE
TYPES OF RESOURCES AND OTHERS
THAT YOU DESCRIBED. THANK YOU
WELCOME. WELL HE KIND OF. THANK
YOU THIS IS REALLY GOING TO
DISCUSS WHAT HE JUST ALREADY
SHARED BECAUSE I WAS LOOKING AT
THE CURRENT STATE OF HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY IN CALIFORNIA THE
REPORT THAT CAME ON IT TALKED
ABOUT VERY STRATEGIC
PROGRAMMATIC APPROACH TO THE
HOUSING CRISIS BUT HE KINDA.
DISCUSS WHAT I WAS GONNA SHARE
AND WANTED A HOUSE BUT THANK
YOU FOR SHARING AND THAT WAS
YOU KNOW ARE WE GONNA MAKE SURE
THAT THERE IS NOT RESOURCES
AVAILABLE AROUND THIS HOUSING
BY THINK I THINKING IMAGE
ANSWER THAT FOR ME ON THE OTHER
THING THAT I'D ADD IS THAT WE
KNOW WE ARE REALLY LOOKING FOR
THESE PROPERTIES TO WHAT TYPE
OF COMMUNITY BENEFITS MIGHT
THEY PROVIDE. AND SO I WOULD
SAY THAT WE HAVE A LOT OF IDEAS
WERE REALLY LOOKING FORWARD TO
SEEING THE CREATIVITY THAT
RESPONDENTS WILL BRING TO THE
R. F. P. ABOUT WHAT TYPES OF
COMMUNITY BENEFITS THESE
PROPERTIES MIGHT BE ABLE TO
OFFER. THANK YOU SENATOR ALAN.
YEAH THE ONE I KNOW THAT OUR
NEXT PANELS CAN BE FOCUSED ON
THIS BUT SINCE YOU'RE HERE AND
PROVIDING YOUR PERSPECTIVE FROM
THE GOVERNMENT SIDE WOULD LOVE
TO GET YOUR SENSE OF THE
INTERACTION SO FAR AND YOUR
ANTICIPATION OF INTERACTION SO
FAR WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
ANY OF YOU KNOW LOTS OF
DIFFERENT ABSOLUTE GOVERNMENT'S
VERY DIFFERENT ATTITUDES ABOUT.
HOUSING. IT SOUNDS LIKE THERE'S
ALREADY BEEN SOME REALLY
FRUITFUL INTERACTION AND SINCE
SYNERGISTIC ENGAGEMENT. YOU CAN
CAN YOU WALK US THROUGH SOME OF
THE- SOME OF THE OPPORTUNITIES
THE CHALLENGES ARE HAVE THERE
BEEN SOME AREAS WHERE YOU'RE
REALLY ANTICIPATING A LOT OF
PUSH BACK. YOU GIVEN GIVEN THE
AND COMMUNITY CONCERNS MIGHT BE
OUT THERE ABOUT ABOUT HOUSING.
LOVE TO WALK THROUGH SOME OF
THE- ACTRESS POLITICS IN
OPPORTUNITIES EXISTING I'LL DO
MY BEST SO YEAH I THINK THERE'S
ALWAYS THE POTENTIAL THAT YOU
KNOW A SITE THAT LOOKS REALLY
GOOD FOR DEVELOPMENTS MIGHT
HAVE SOME LOCAL ON PALATABILITY
WE WOULD NECESSARILY NO WE
DON'T KNOW AND SO THAT THAT
IT'S ALWAYS A POTENTIAL RISK OR
AN ISSUE INSOFAR AS WE ARE
AWARE OBVIOUSLY YOU KNOW WE
LIKE THOSE SITES AND HAVE
PROACTIVE CONVERSATIONS WITH
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. WE'VE GOT SO
LIKE SO AS I MENTIONED EARLIER
A LOT OF THE COMIC CON
CONVERSATIONS IT HAPPENED HAVE
BEEN DISTILLED FACILITATED.
THROUGH VARIOUS MEANS WE
PROBABLY INTERACTED WITH SAY.
TWO DOZEN OR SO DIFFERENT LOCAL
ENTITIES SO MORE POPULOUS
ENTITIES. IN TERMS OF OUR SITES
THEMSELVES AND IT WE'VE WE'VE
WE'VE BEEN VERY CLEAR EVERYBODY
WE CAN'T DISCLOSE SITE EXOR
WIRES THE BECAUSE YOU KNOW BE
PAYING WHEN THESE GUYS REACHED
OUT WE MAY HAVE GOTTEN A YES
FOR THE DEPARTMENT YET SO WE'VE
BEEN PRIMARILY INTERACTING
AROUND SITES THAT THEY
THEMSELVES HAVE SAID WE'VE BEEN
EYEING THIS SITE IN OUR
JURISDICTION THE LAST TWENTY
FIVE YEARS. NOTHING'S BEING
DONE WITH IT TORE IT LOOKS LIKE
IT'S UNDER UTILIZED OR THEY
COULD DO SOMETHING ELSE WITH IT
AND SO. THOSE HAVE BEEN THAT
THE PRIMARY NATURE THE
INTERACTIONS WITH THE LOCALS.
WE EXPECT. PUBLISHING OF THE
HEAT MAP TO CHANGE THAT DYNAMIC
WE EXPECT THERE TO BE AN INFLUX
OF. OF MORE OF THOSE
CONVERSATIONS BOTH LOOK
AMENITIES AND FOR MEMBERS WE
ALSO EXPECT. TO BEGIN THE MORE
FORMALIZED OUT REACHED WITH
THEM WITH THEM ABOUT OUR
PARTICULAR SITES. TRYING TO
GATHER LESSONS LEARNED WE PLAN
ON DOING THAT IN A WAY THAT IS
STILL SORT OF PRIORITIZE
WORKLOAD PERSPECTIVE SO. ENOUGH
SITE MIGHT BE YOU KNOW CHARGE
SEVEN. IT PROBABLY WON'T HAVE
THE SAME LEVEL CONVERSATION
THAT I TRUMP'S ONE OR TWO SITE
IS GOING TO HAVE. AT LEAST IN
THE BEGINNING. WE HAVE AND I
KNOW IN THEIR NUMBERS CAN I
COME UP IN A MINUTE BUT WE'VE
ALSO. HAD SOME THROUGH
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE LEAGUE
OF CITIES AS WELL. WE HAVE SOME
TENTATIVE PLANS TO DO A WEAPON.
ARE TO THE MEMBERS FOR EXAMPLE
UPON THE RELEASE OF THE MAP.
OUR GOAL TO MILLIONS TO GET THE
WORD OUT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE HEAT MAP ITSELF IS
FUNCTIONAL USABLE NOT JUST
FROM. OUR PERSPECTIVE BUT ALSO
FROM LOCAL DEVELOPERS AND LOCAL
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AGENCIES AS
WELL. SO IT'S BEEN VERY FOCUSED
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE LOCALS
AND I THINK THE TENOR AND TONE
OF THAT WILL CHANGE ONCE THE
MAP IS OUT AND- WEBER TALK
ABOUT SPECIFIC PROPERTIES AND
ISSUES AND THEY HAVE. BUT IT'S
BEEN ACTIVE IN SURPRISINGLY.
FRUITFUL AND NO CONCERNS BEEN
RAISED SO FAR NO. NO REAL
ISSUES WITH ANY LOOK OF AGENCY
HAVE COME UP. CAN YOU GIVE ME A
SENSE OF HOW MUCH. COERCIVE
POWER THE STATE HAS. WITHIN THE
CONTEXT OF THE EXECUTIVE ORDER.
AND HOW YEAH WHAT WAS IS THIS
IS THIS IS THE TRUE REALLY TERM
EARLY VOLUNTARY PARTNERSHIP
THING OR IT OR IS THERE A BIT
OF A STICK ASSOCIATED I THINK
THAT THE BEST REVENGE THE
QUESTION IS. IS IT'S REALLY
COMPLICATED. THIRD EVERYTHING
FROM YOU KNOW ALL ALL TAKE OFF
A COUPLE OF THINGS ONE YOU KNOW
EVEN EVEN IF THE STATE COULD
COME IN AND SAY YOU KNOW WHAT
WE'RE DROPPING A UNIT REGULARS
PROPERTY NO ONE CAN GAINS THAT
WE STILL HAVE TO CONNECT TO
LOCAL POWER WATER SEWER GASES
THOSE CONVERSATIONS HAPPEN NO
MATTER WHAT AND THEN. AND THEN
SEE WHAT PLAYS INTO THINGS AS
WELL. ANOTHER SOME THERE'S SOME
HOUSING EXEMPTIONS FOR SEQUEL
BUT THOSE ARE SPECIFICIT DOES
REQUIRE YOU KNOW BY PRESENTING
A SOURCE ULTIMATELY AND SO
THERE'S A NUMBER OF A VARIETY
OF CONVERSATIONS THAT THERE'S
NO. THERE'S NO WAY I THINK FOR
THE STATE TO COME IN AND JUST.
KIND OF BUSINESS TABLES THEY
WERE PUTTING SOMETHING THERE
WITHOUT SOME DEGREE OF
INVOLVEMENT OUR PREFERENCE
OBVIOUSLY EVER TALK ABOUT
PRIORITIZING SITES YOU KNOW
GOING BACK TO BEEN DIAGRAM.
THERE'S THE FOLKS WHO WHO ARE
OKAY WITH IT THANKS TO ONE OF
THE FOLKS ARE SUPPORTIVE OF IT.
I THINK YOU KNOW IN TERMS OF
SPEEDING GETTING SITES OUT
WE'RE OBVIOUSLY CAN BE
PARTNERING WITH THOSE ENTITIES
WHO WERE HOUSING IS NEEDED
WHERE TO GET A GOOD SITE AND
WHERE THEY ARE SUPPORTIVE AND
ENGAGED THOSE ARE THE ONES I
THINK THEY'RE GONNA GET. THE
EARLIEST DEVELOPMENTS COME OUT.
BUT BEYOND THAT YEAH WE- THE
THAT THE QUEEN OF THE STATE
ISN'T SUBJECT TO. YOU KNOW.
LOCAL ZONING AND THINGS LIKE
THAT SO. WHILE WE ARE NOT
CITIES OF THOSE THINGS OUR
FOCUS HAS BEEN WE ONE HAVE AN
ACTIVE PARTNERSHIP BECAUSE WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE'S- THERE
REALLY IS A TIE BETWEEN WHAT
WE'RE DOING AND THE COMMITTEE
WERE BUILDING HOUSING. IN
SOMEONE'S BACKYARD WE RECOGNIZE
THAT AND WANT TO BE. WILL BE
GOOD NEIGHBORS. AND ARE YOU
LOOKING FOR LEGISLATION THAT
MIGHT ASSIST WITH. GETTING
THESE. PROJECTS OUT FASTER
THERE HASN'T BEEN ANY
CONVERSATION ABOUT POTENTIAL
LEGISLATION. OKAY OBVIOUSLY
WILL BE INTERESTED IN AND THAT
AND I THINK YEAH I MEAN I THINK
EVERYBODY. IS LOOKING FOR WAYS
TO. BIG EXPAND OUR HOUSING
STOCK AND IN DOING SO IN A WAY
THAT'S. BOTH RESPECTFUL OF
LOCALS WHILE ALSO UNDERSTANDING
THAT YOU KNOW YOU CAN'T. BM
MEET EVERY CONCERN THAT MIGHT
BE THERE AT A LOCAL WINE AND
ARE YOU WANTED ADDED YEAH I
JUST SAY THAT FOR SOME OF THE
JURISDICTIONS THAT ALREADY
STEPPED FORWARD AND DESCRIBE
THEIR WILLINGNESS THERE
DEMONSTRATING THAT IN A FEW
DIFFERENT WAYS THEY MAY BE
EXAMINING WHAT KIND OF LOCAL
FUNDING THEY HAVE AVAILABLE TO
COMMIT TO THE DEAL WHETHER
THAT'S FROM THE LOCAL
JURISDICTION ITSELF FOR FROM
THE LOCAL HOUSING AUTHORITY. SO
THEY'RE EXPLORING THOSE THINGS
THEY'RE ALSO THINKING ABOUT
WHAT THEIR PERMIT PROCESSES
GENERALLY AND WHILE IT MIGHT
NOT APPLY STRICTLY HERE THEY
pMAY HAVE A LOCAL LIAISON THAT
COULD REALLY HELP FACILITATE
SOME OF THE COMMUNITY OUTREACH
FACILITATE ANY OF THE
DISCUSSIONS WITH LOCAL PUBLIC
WORKS AND THINGS LIKE THAT SO
THOSE. ARE GOOD DEMONSTRATIONS
OF WILLINGNESS BEYOND JUST
STATING CELL RIGHT BUT REALLY
SHOWING THAT THEY ARE BEING
INTROSPECTIVE AND HOW THEY CAN
CONTINUE TO FACILITATE THIS
PARTNERSHIP. MIGHT BE SOME
OTHER QUALITATIVE THINGS THAT
WE WOULD LOOK FOR MYSELF FOR
ONE FINAL QUESTION WHAT CAN YOU
GIVE US A SENSE OF WHAT SORT OF
ENVIRONMENTAL CONSIDERATIONS
ARE BEING TAKEN IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THIS HOUSING.
YOU KNOW LEAD CERTIFICATION AND
YOU KNOW OTHER AT BEST
PRACTICES GIVEN OUR. OUR OTHER
KIND OF BROADER SUSTAINABILITY
GOALS AS A STATE. YEAH I MEAN I
THINK. WE WILL BE ENCOURAGING
DEVELOPERS TO. ALONG THOSE
LINES. OTHER THERE'S YOU KNOW A
EXISTING EXECUTIVE ORDERS THAT
GENTLY GOVERN HOW WE BUILD
THINGS IN THE STATE IS THE OLD
EXECUTIVE ORDER REQUIRES THE
SILVER FOR EXAMPLE THE MINIMUM.
WE'RE STILL DOING THE ANALYSIS
TO SEE YOU KNOW WHETHER THOSE
THINGS. APPLY ULTIMATELY TO THE
SORT OF DEVELOPER LET
PROPOSALS. BUT EXECUTIVE ORDER
IS PRETTY CLEAR AND DIRECTING
US TO SCORE FAVORABLY THOSE WHO
TO FOCUS ON AND MORE
SUSTAINABLE DEVELOPMENT. THAT'S
I THINK BOTH THE MATERIALITY AS
AN APPROACH AND APPROACHES SO
THAT'S AIMING AT CARBON
NEUTRALITY THROUGH.
ELECTRIFICATION WHETHER THAT'S
YOU KNOW INSTALLATION OF SELECT
PANELS VERSES AN OFFSITE BPA
MILL ALL ALL THOSE THINGS ARE
BEING ARE GONNA BE LOOKED AT
THE OUR FEES. BUT WE DON'T HAVE
AT PRESENT AT LEAST LIKE A
MINIMUM SET UP TO SENSIBLE
CRITERIA BEYOND WANTING TO MAKE
SURE THAT THIS IS APPROACH CPOS
ASSEMBLY. AND IN A COST
EFFECTIVE WAY LIKE WE DO WITH
THE STATE DEVELOPMENTS. AND
THEN I'D ADD THAT A LOT OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FINANCE
MECHANISMS DO REQUIRE SOME
DEGREE OF CONSIDERATION FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL. SUSTAINABILITY
WITHIN THE PROPERTY AND THEN
FURTHER KIND OF LOOKING AT
OPERATIONAL SUSTAINABILITY OR
EVEN SUSTAINABILITY OF
HOUSEHOLDS THAT ARE LIVING AT
THESE PROPERTIES. THIS BECOMES
REALLY IMPORTANT OF WHY WE
MIGHT CONSIDER LOCATION OF THE
PROPERTY SO MAKING SURE THAT
IT'S CONNECTED TO TRANSIT
NETWORKS. GOOD HIGHER QUALITY
TRANSIT AND THINGS LIKE THAT SO
REALLY BEING ABLE TO LIMIT THE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTIONS BY
DECREASING THE AMOUNT OF THE M.
T. THAT'S COMING FROM THESE
HOUSEHOLDS JUST BY VIRTUE OF
HAVING THEM CLOSER TO JOBS
CLOSER TO EDUCATION. CLOSER TO
TRANSIT WHAT ELSE IF IT'S NOT
GOING TO CONTINUE TO TRAFFIC I
MEAN THAT THE ALL THE SORTS OF
THINGS OF THE KINDS OF THINGS I
THINK THAT'LL MAKE DON. CAM
COMMUNITIES ON THE GROUND FEEL
MORE COMFORTABLE. JUST SO I
UNDERSTAND THE PLAN A BASIC
MECHANISMS YOU HAVE. BASICALLY
A FIND. AND THEN YOU YOU YOU'RE
GETTING DEVELOPERS. FUTURE OF
MATCHING UP SPACE. WITH A MALE
ALL THESE PRODUCTS WILL BE
DEVELOPED BY PRIVATE.
DEVELOPERS YEAH THE AMBIENT ME
ANTI THE INTENTION IS THAT THE
STATE BRINGS THE PROPER TO THE
TABLE AD WE BRING THE ABILITY
TO LEASE AT VERY LOW COST AND
LONG TERM DEVELOPERS WOULD COME
AND THEY WOULD PROPOSE BE
AWARDED IT THEY WOULD BUILD OWN
AND OPERATE THE IMPROVEMENTS
WITH THE WITH THE FUNDAMENTAL
LONG TERM GROUND LEASE TO THEM.
SO IT'S ALL OF FOR IT'S A IT'S
A I HAD A PERSON FROM HOUSING
MINISTER THEREFORE I 2% IT
WOULD IT WOULD DEPEND ON THE
MARKET ITSELF THE TYPES OF
HOUSING SUBSIDIES THAT ARE
AVAILABLE HOW THE DEAL PENCILS
HOW MUCH ARE PROPERTY VALUE
THAT'S US. SOME OF THE
PROPERTIES MAY BE ON A PERCENT.
OTHERS ARE GOING TO BE MORE
TRADITIONAL IN A MARKET FOR ALL
MIXES. BUT MORE TRADITIONAL AS
IN 10% OF OUR HOUSING. NO I
THINK WE COULD WE ARE EXPLORING
MIXED INCOME DEVELOPMENTS AND
FACT IS THERE A MINIMUM
AFFORDABLE HOUSING NOT SPELLED
OUT IN THE EXECUTIVE ORDER AND
SO I THINK THIS IS MORE THAT
WILL EXPLORE WITH THE REAL
ESTATE DUE DILIGENCE WHAT CAN
THE PROPERTY BY ITSELF SUPPORT
WHAT OTHER FINANCING COULD COME
IN TO HELP SUPPORT DEEPER
AFFORDABILITY. AND SO THAT'S
SOME OF THE FACTORS THAT WE
DON'T YET KNOW UNTIL WE GET
DEEPER INTO THE SITES I'D SAY
THAT THERE DOES SEEM TO BE A
STRONG FOCUS ON AFFORDABILITY
IN EACH SHE BEATS ROLE IN EACH
CITY SERVICE OF PROVIDING
AFFORDABLE OR LOANS TO CREATE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING I THINK THAT
THAT IS INTENTIONAL RIGHT SO
WILL BE CONSIDERING THE WAYS
THAT WE CAN SUPPORT. ON THESE
DEVELOPERS AND EXPLORING THE
FINANCING OPTION RIGHT MISS
HOUSING WINNING TO OUR FIND
FINANCING ALONE THIS WAS WHEN
YOU'RE GIVING THEM THAT THAT
PRETTY CONSIDERABLE GIFT OF. A
FREE LAND RIGHT WHICH DOES HELP
DISCOUNT IT QUITE A BIT I WOULD
THINK SO YEAH BUT YOU KNOW WE
HAVE HEARD FROM OTHER LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO THERE'S YOU KNOW
SOME LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THAT ARE
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THE LACK
OF MODERATE INCOME HOUSING SURE
SO SOMETHING LIKE SOME MODERATE
UNITS PERHAPS SOME ABOVE
MODERATE UNITS COULD HELP
OFFSET THE DEEPER AFFORDABILITY
AND STILL GET TO VERY LOW SO.
THIS IS WHERE WE DON'T WANT TO
LIMIT THE CREATIVITY THAT THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPERS
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATIONS MIGHT BE ABLE TO
BRING AS THEY. LOOK AT SOME OF
THE PROPERTIES THAT WE HAVE
AVAILABLE. BUT NO NOTHING
SPELLED OUT ABOUT SPECIFIC
AFFORDABILITY MIXES WITHIN THE
L. JUST A ALONG THE LINES OF
THAT QUESTION. YEAH THE
GOVERNOR I REALLY. APPRECIATE
HAVE A PRETTY THE GOVERNOR'S
YOU APPROACH TO THAT ARE
PROVIDING. OF THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING THAT OUR MEETING. YOU
KNOW THE REGIONAL HOUSING NEEDS.
I GUESS MY CONCERN HERE IS HOW
DO WE GO ABOUT WITH THE LOCAL
COMMUNITIES. AND NOT CREATE A
SIMILAR TYPE OF SITUATION WHERE
YOU HAVE THE NIMBIS OR SOMEBODY
JUST COMING HERE EVEN WHERE THE
STATE'S. GIVEN THESE HOUSING
THE GOOD THIS LAND IN. SO I'M
I'M INTERESTED IN WHAT THE
ENTITLEMENT PROCESS YOU KNOW MY
LOOK LIKE IF IT'S PREMATURE ON
THAT THAT'S FINE THAT'S THE
ACCEPTABLE AT A ANSWER BUT I
BUT WHAT I'M HOPING IS THAT WE
HAVE THE ABILITY TO YOU KNOW
WORK WITH CITY STAFF EVERYTHING
AND NOT. PROVIDE THIS POLITICAL.
SOMETIMES DIATRIBE TO DOT MY
BACKYARD. AND YOUR WORK CLOSELY
WITH THE DEVELOPER THE
NONPROFIT COMMUNITY IN THE
STATE IN THE IN THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WITHOUT SETTING UP.
THESE MASSIVE PUBLIC HEARINGS
TO YOUR WHICH MADE TO SWAY
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS I EAT COUNCIL
MEMBERS FROM THE SUPPORTING A
PROJECT LIKE THAT. YEAH AND TO
SALAS POINT I MEAN THERE I
THINK THAT'S WHERE THE STATE'S.
A LOT OF THAT FACTORS AND I
MEAN WE AREN'T SUBJECT
TECHNICALLY TO TONING OR
PLANNING COMMISSION APPROVALS
ARE THOSE SORTS OF THINGS.
SEQUEL IN THE LAST MINUTES IT'S
VERY MUCH A PUBLIC INPUT
PROCESS AND SO YOU KNOW THAT'S
THAT'S WHAT THAT'S DESIGNED TO
DO IS LIST OF IMPORTANCE OTHER
CERTAINLY GONNA BE THAT ELEMENT
TO IT. BUT YEAH I MEAN I THINK
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS NATURALLY HAVE TO
GO THROUGH IN THEIR OWN
JURISDICTIONS WE ARE SUBJECT TO
AND BEING ABLE TO KIND OF DO
THAT IN A COLLABORATIVE WAY
WITH THEM THAT STILL. IS NOT TO
THE PORTAL TO THE COMMUNITY BUT
DOES FOCUS. ON ON DEVELOPMENT
IN A RESPONSIBLE WAY IS KIND OF
ORACLE. SENATOR RUBIO DID
SENATOR NIELSEN THANK YOU. HAVE
A QUESTION ABOUT REDEVELOPMENT
LAND I KNOW DOWNTOWN A LOT OF
LOCAL MUNICIPALITIES PURCHASE
AND WITH THE DEVELOPMENT
FUNDING AND THEN WHEN IT WENT
AWAY HOW SOME OF THE LAND WAS
LEFT IN LIMBO. BY WAY OF
EXAMPLE I REMEMBER WE HAD A
PARCEL WHERE IT WAS
REDEVELOPMENT A BOLD SITES VERY
SMALL AND THERE WAS A PIECE IN
THE CENTER THAT WE'RE GONNA
PURCHASE FOR MY PRIVATE OWNER
SO THAT WE CAN CONSOLIDATE THE
LAN AND CREATE SOMETHING BIG
BUT- THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN AND ONE
AWAY BUT THOSE TWO PARCELS WERE
STILL LEFT. IN LIMBO SO. TO
SPEAK CAN YOU SPEAK TO THAT AND
HOW ARGUE. GOING TO DETERMINE
LIKE FOR EXAMPLE IN THAT CASE I
JUST EXPRESS IT WOULD BE VERY
DIFFICULT FOR YOU TO SEE. THAT
THAT THERE'S A POTENTIAL THERE
BECAUSE THEY'RE TOO SMALL
PIECES ARE YOU GOING INTO
CITIES AND ASKING FOR
INFORMATION FROM PRIOR LAND.
HOW WE WOULD INVITE ANY CITY
THAT HAS AN INVENTORY AVAILABLE
TO CONSIDER HOW THEIR INVENTORY
MIGHT ALIGN WITH OURS AND SO I
THINK ONCE WE REVEALED A HEAT
MAP THAT WILL BE MUCH MORE
TRANSPARENT. AND I THINK THERE
IS SOME PENDING LEGISLATION
KIND OF SPEAKING TO THIS RIGHT
NOW THAT ASIDE. WE'LL BE ABLE
TO HAVE THOSE CONVERSATIONS IN
THAT SPECIFIC SCENARIO THAT YOU
DESCRIBED IF THE FORMER
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCY WANTED TO
TALK TO US ABOUT HOW SOME OF
OUR SITES MAY BE ADJACENT OR
HOW WE MABEL TO BE ABLE TO SWAP
OR COMBINED. THOSE ARE THE TYPE-OF CONVERSATIONS THE TREASONS
MENTIONING WE EXPECT TO BE
HAVING MORE OF I'M WE DO KNOW
THAT WHETHER IT'S FORMER
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES
LOCALITIES ON ME YOU KNOW
CITIES OR COUNTIES. PUBLIC
HOUSING AUTHORITIES TRANSIT
AGENCIES THERE'S A LOT OF
ENTITIES THAT DO HAVE PUBLICLY
OWNED LAND THAT MAY FIT THOSE
TYPES OF DESCRIPTIONS THAT YOU
JUST SHARED SO. WE. LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING HOW THOSE
INVENTORIES MY MATCH UP WITH
OURS. YEAH I ONLY ADD THAT YEAH
UNFORTUNATELY ALL WE ARE AWARE
OF ARE THE PROPERTIES AT THE
STATE OWNS AND CONTROLS. AND SO
THOSE THOSE SYNERGIES WE ARE
KIND OF DEPENDENT ON THE LOCALS
FROM TO BRING UP AND PARTNER
WITH US ON. SO AT THIS POINT WE
ARE GOING TO DO OF SOME KIND OF
EDUCATIONAL CAMPAIGN SOUL.
CITIES TO UNDERSTAND THAT THIS
IS A PROCESS THAT YOU'RE GOING
THROUGH AND THAT THAT
INFORMATION WOULD BE VITAL.
OKAY THE WHAT WAS THE MAP IS
PUBLISHED WE ARE EXPECTING TO
DO A SIGNIFICANT ABOUT REACHES
BACK THANK YOU. CENTER NIELSEN.
HARDING IS AN ISSUE THAT MUST
BE. COGNIZANT OF. OVER THE
YEARS. BUDGET PARTICULARLY I
WATCH THESE AGENCIES HAVE
PROPERTIES. ONE H. BERDIRI
IMPOSSIBLE SOMETIMES TO GET THE
INVENTORY OF WHAT THEY HAVE I
KNOW RECENT EFFORTS MADE BY
OTHER MEMBERS HERE IN THE LAST
TEN YEARS TO GET INFORMATION
FROM AGENCIES ABOUT WHAT
PROPERTY THEY HAVE THAT IS
ACCESS BUT WE DON'T HAVE ANY
DATA. I WOULD ASSUME THAT IT IS
GETTING BETTER OF THESE
AGENCIES BEING FORCED TO OR A
REWARDED IF THEY'LL BE COMING
FORTH I MEAN THERE HAS TO BE AN
ACCOUNTABILITY BECAUSE AGENCIES
HISTORICALLY DON'T WANT TO JUST
PUT STUFF OUT ON THE TABLE WE
ALWAYS MAY NEED THAT FIFTEEN
YEARS FROM NOW. SO THAT'S
THAT'S KIND OF WHY THIS
EXECUTIVE ORDER I THINK IS SO
GROUND BREAKING INTO THE- THERE
IS IT'S CALLED THE STATE
PROPERTY INVENTORY EITHER THERE
IS A AN ANNUAL REPORTING
PROCESS THAT APARTMENTS ARE
OBLIGATED TO FOLLOW TO REPORT.
ALL EXISTING PROPERTY TO D. G.
SB CAN. BE COMPILED INTO
INVENTORY THERE ARE SOME
EXEMPTIONS IN STATUTE FOR
REPORTERS IN ME UP DATA BURIED
A LITTLE BIT AND ALSO REPORTED
SO THERE'S YOU KNOW SOME GAPS.
WHICH IS WHY WE ACTUALLY TO
COUNTY ASSESSOR DATA AS OPPOSED
TO RELYING TO IT BECAUSE WE
KNOW THAT THERE HAVE BEEN GAP
HISTORICALLY WE EVEN LEAVE
ANYTHING OUT. BUT AT THAT
PROCESS DOES EXIST AND THAT'S
WHERE DEPARTMENTS ARE OBLIGATED
TO REPORT ACCESS TO US BUT
AGAIN WE GET YOU KNOW ONE TWO
YEAR TYPE OF THING. AND SO THIS
EXECUTIVE ORDER REQUIRES TO GO
OUT AND SAY INDEPENDENT ALL
THAT REPORTING INDEPENDENT OF
DEPARTMENT SELF SUPPORTING.
LET'S ACTUALLY LOOK AT PROPERTY
AND SEE WHAT'S OUT THERE AND
WHAT APPEARS TO BE UNDER
UTILIZED SO. THIS IS CREATED AN
ACCESS LIST. THAT WE WOULD
NEVER HAVE ARRIVED AT HAD IT
NOT BEEN FOR THE EXECUTIVE
ORDER. THE NAME ISSUE THAT THE
CHAIR HAS JUST BROUGHT TO OUR
ATTENTION IS ALSO. OF MANIFEST
IMPORTANCE AND IT GOES BACK
MANY MANY YEARS. FOR EXAMPLE
PEOPLE WANT TO MOVE OUT INTO
THE MORE RURAL AREAS FOR THE
AESTHETICS. THE BEAUTY OF IT.
BUT THEN WHEN WE TRY TO SECURE
FARM WORKER HOUSING. THEN HE'S
COMING NO NO NO NO NOT HERE.
ARE YOU WHAT WHAT ARE YOUR
TECHNIQUES TO DEAL WITH THOSE
KIND OF LOCAL. NIMBY
IMPEDIMENTS THAT COME FORWARD
HOW DO WE CONVINCE PEOPLE THAT
HATE YOU KNOW. YOU'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO TAKE YOUR SHARE. BUT
WE'VE HAD ISSUES OF THAT
RELATED TO THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING MANDATE. COMMUNITIES
TRYING TO WELL YOU KNOW NOT US
NOW IT'S. THAT THAT'S THE
THAT'S A HUGE PROBLEM AND IT'S
GONNA HAVE TO BE WHEN YOU
WRESTLE WITH DAILY I'M SURE.
YEAH IT HONESTLY NOT TO START
TO GO BACK TO A THEME BUT- WE
MAY BLACKOUT NEVER SINGLE
PARCELS IN A PLACE HER BODY
WANTS TO DEVELOP WE MIGHT HAVE
THE EXACT OPPOSITE THAT WE
REALLY DON'T KNOW IN SOME
CASES. BUT YEAH INSOFAR AS WE
COME ACROSS THAT AND KIND OF
BACK TO THE CHAIRS POINT IN IN
MY ANSWER. WE DO HAVE.
EXEMPTIONS BEING SOVEREIGN THAT
WE DON'T HAVE TO GO QUITE
THROUGH THE SAME A POOL
PLANNING PROCESS. AGAIN WANT TO
BE GOOD PARTNERS ONE OF LOCAL
OUT REACH ALL THAT ABSOLUTELY
BUT WE AREN'T SUBJECT TO. SOME
OF THE- IN A PLANNING
COMMISSION VOTES IN APPROVAL
SET UP OR DOWN HOUSING IN THE
PAST. YOU KNOW SEE COULD NOT
WITHSTANDING WE DO HAVE YOU
KNOW. STE SOVEREIGNTY OVER
LOCAL PLANNING IN THOSE ISSUES
SO. THOSE CAN BE LEVERAGED BUT
AGAIN WE ARE LOOKING TO
PRIORITIZE SITES WHERE. THAT
THAT SYNERGY BETWEEN US AND
LOCAL NEED AND WANT IS WELL
ALIGNED. AND THEN WE CERTAINLY
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THERE WILL BE
A GOOD BIT OF COMMUNITY OUT
REACH THAN ANY OF THE SELECTED
DEVELOPERS WOULD NEED TO ENGAGE
AND SELL. OUT IMAGINE THAT THAT
WILL BE PART OF WHAT WE'RE
CONSIDERING. I'M THROUGH THE R.
F. P. AND THEN REALLY LOOKING
FOR THAT LOCAL PARTNERSHIP OR
WAY FINDING SO THAT THAT LOCAL
LIAISON. CAN REALLY HELP THE
DEVELOPER NAVIGATE WHO ARE THE-FOLKS THAT NEED TO BE TALKED TO
WHAT TYPE OF WHAT IS GOOD
COMMUNITY OUTREACH LOOK LIKE IN
THAT COMMUNITY. AND WHERE SOME
OF THE STUMBLING BLOCKS. I'M SO
THOSE ARE THINGS THAT WILL
CERTAINLY BE FOCUSING. ON AND
MAKING SURE THAT THE DEVELOPERS
OF A PLAN TO DEAL WITH. THERE'S
A NEW DYNAMIC IN THIS A LAST
ALL SAY ON THIS FOR NOW BUT.
THE DIFFICULTIES THAT WE'VE HAD
WITH BUYERS WERE LITERALLY
DEALING WITH THAT EVERY DAY.
AND WE'VE HAD HOUSING PROBLEMS.
SEVERELY EXACERBATED I WAS UP
IN TO GO YESTERDAY AT MEETINGS
ON THIS VERY ISSUE. AND WE ARE
NOW HAVING HUGE HUGE ISSUES.
NOT JUST PROVIDING NEW BUT
REBUILDING. THAT'S GOING TO BE
A HUGE DYNAMIC IN THE- AND WHAT
WILL BE THEN OUR POLICIES
RELATED TO MANAGING FORCING
WHILE LANCE TO DIMINISH THE
FIRE POTENTIAL. OUT THERE SO
THAT ALSO FACTORS INTO IS IT
NOT. IT DOES PART OF THE THAT
THE STORE ABSOLUTELY IT DOES
MEAN PART OF THE SCREENING
PROCESS THAT WE'VE WE'VE GONE
THROUGH IS TO LOOK AT WHERE
THESE PROPERTY SAID IN
RELATIONSHIP TO FIRE HAZARD
AREAS DIFFERENT BILL THE AREAS.
YOU KNOW THERE ARE SOME
PROPERTIES AT APARTMENT MAYES
SAID YES TO FALLS IN UP IN A
RED ZONE AND SO KIND OF GOING
BACK TO OUR OUR NUMBER OF YES
PROPERTIES FLUCTUATING A LITTLE
SORT OF THINGS THAT'LL MAKE
SOMETHING FALL OFF OR OR AT THE
BACK ON. AS TIME GOES ON SO
YEAH THERE'S WE HAVE TAKE A
LOOK AT THAT WE ALSO ARE
COGNIZANT OF NOT. WANTING TO
BUILD THE PLACE THAT IS. YOU
KNOW MA'AM. CAN YOU SHOULD BE
BRING DOWN LATER. OKAY I JUST
WOULD CONCLUDE BY SAYING
ASSUMING THAT THERE. MIGHT BE
HAPPEN TO LOOK AT SOME
STATUTORY CHANGES DOWN THE WAY
TO FACILITATE YOUR GOALS. SIR
HUESO. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIRMAN ALAN THANK
EVERYONE HERE FOR THIS AMAZING
A PRESENTATION AND THIS IS JUST
A TREMENDOUS UNDERTAKING I HAVE
TO COMMEND ALL OF YOU ONE I GOT
ELECTED TO CITY COUNCIL IN IN
THE TWO THOUSAND SIX AND WE'RE
GOING THROUGH A VERY SIMILAR
HOUSING CRISIS BACK THEN WE HAD.
ALSO SENSE OF URGENCY OF
CREATING NEW STOCK AND- I DID
SOMETHING SIMILAR WITH THE CITY
OF SAN DIEGO OF IDENTIFYING
UNUSED PARCELS AND FIND TRYING
TO FIND WHICH ONES WERE HELPFUL
AND WAS VERY INTERESTING. THAT
THERE WAS A VERY LONG LIST O
PROPERTY THAT CITY DID NOT EVEN
HAVE AN INVENTORY. AND. THAT
WAS A VERY TROUBLED DEPARTMENT
RE REAL ESTATE ASSETS
DEPARTMENT BECAUSE THEY HAD ALL
THIS LAND THAT THEY DIDN'T EVEN
KNOW. WHAT IT WAS AND WHERE IT
WAS AND IT TOOK A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF TIME TO IDENTIFY WHAT
THOSE PARCELS WARNER MAKES ME
THINK. IN OF THAT'S THAT THE
STATE HAS THAT IN THE COUNTIES
HAVE THAT IN CITIES HOW MUCH
LAND IS PUBLICLY ON. THERE'S
BEEN FORGOTTEN. THAT SITTING
OUT THERE NOT ACHIEVING OF
BENEFIT TO THESE COMMUNITIES I
CAN BE UTILIZED. I'M NOT I'M
NOT A I'M NOT. AT IN ANY CASE
THINK IN THAT YOU SHOULD GO
AFTER THAT BECAUSE. BUT YOU
KNOW KIND OF BEGS THE QUESTION
OF THESE LATENT ASSETS THEY'RE
NOT PAYING A PROPERTY TAX
WHAT'S THE VALUE TO OUR STATE.
OF PUTTING THESE ASSETS BACK TO
WORK EVEN IF WE WERE TO SELL
THEM IF THEY'RE NOT. ARE THERE
SOME VALUE IN AN AND LOOKING IN
THAT BECAUSE THAT COULD VERY
MUCH PAY. FOR THIS DEVELOPMENT.
AND ALSO BRING ADDITIONAL
REVENUE TO THE STATE FOR FUTURE
YEARS A SOMETHING I THINK WE
SHOULD LOOK AT THAT FOURTY FOUR
THOUSAND PARCELS THAT'S- THAT'S
A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF LAND YOU
KNOW EVEN IF I UNDERSTAND SOME
OF THESE ARE REMNANTS OF OTHER
PARCELS THAT WERE USED FOR ON
RAMPS FOR FREE WAY. OR OR FOR
YOU KNOW THIS THIRD THERE'S
GOTTA BE A WAY TO IDENTIFY THE
ONES ARE USABLE IT. AND IF
THEY'RE NOT NESTLE USABLE FOR
HOUSING THAT COULD BE USED FOR
AGRICULTURE OR SOMETHING ELSE
OR TO HELP. FINALIZE A PARTIAL
THAT WOULD BE USED TO BRING
REVENUE TO THE STATE TO ALSO
HELP WITH PAYING THE COSTS OF
SUPPORTING THIS HOUSING SO THAT
MAY BE KIND OF THE NEXT STEP IN
THIS PROCESS OF. IF WE WANT TO
DO THAT BUT- GENERALLY. I
RECOMMEND THAT AS WE GO THROUGH
THIS PROCESS THAT WE ESTABLISH
SOME KIND OF. AS A RESOLUTION
OR AN ACTUAL BILL A LAW KIND OF
ESTABLISHING THE URGENCY AT A
CRISIS IN CALIFORNIA SOMETHING
THAT ACCOMPANIES THIS ACTION TO
TRUMP ALL OTHER. LAWS IN TERMS
OF THE NECESSITY AND THE
URGENCY TO ADD TO THE HOUSING
STOCK. IF WE DID THAT IN IN IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THIS WHO WOULD
HELP TO STREAMLINE THE PROCESS
OF GETTING THESE PROJECTS
APPROVED. I DO RECOMMEND
WORKING LOCAL COMMUNITIES TO
MINIMIZE THE CONFLICT AND
ENSURE THAT WERE WEST WE BUILD
HOUSING THERE THEY'RE WORKING
IN TWO. THE EXISTING. OUR
COMMUNITY PLANS THAT THEY'RE
CONSISTENT WITH THE ZONING IN
THE AREA THAT THE DESIGN IS
CONSISTENT WITH WOULD LOCAL.
CODES I THINK THAT CAN BE DONE
IT IN A WAY THAT WOULD HELP
MAKE THESE. PROJECTS UP QUICKLY
BUILDABLE BUT ALSO SUSTAINABLE
OVER SEVERAL YEARS IT'S IS VERY
IMPORTANT TO DO THAT TO MAKE
SURE WE SUPPORT OUR COMMUNITIES
AS WE BUILD THIS NEST NECESSARY
HOUSING. AND THE NEXT THING AS
YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT. MAKING
SURE THAT WE GIVE THE
DEVELOPERS THE DISCRETION TO
COME UP WITH A BUSINESS PLAN
THAT FITS. YOU KNOW THE PARTS
ON THE LOCATION I THINK THAT
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT. BUT WE
ALSO HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE BUILDING A WORKFORCE
HOUSE IN THAT WERE BUILDING
HOUSING FOR THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT THIS HOUSE IT'S
NOT GOING TO BE USED. AS A
VACATION HOME MORE AIRBNB. WE
GOT TO FIND A WAY TO ENSURE
THAT ONE THIS HOUSING IT'S
BILL'S GOING TO BE BUILT FOR
CALIFORNIANS. IT'S GOING TO BE
BUILT TO ALLEVIATE THE HOUSING
CRISIS. AND NOT FOR ANYTHING
OTHER THAN THAT AND THAT I
THINK HAS TO BE CLEAR IN THIS
PROCESS TO WHOEVER. INTENDS TO
DEVELOP. PROVIDING THE SUPPLY
IS CRITICAL. AND IT BUT IT'S
GOTTA BE SUPPLY FOR ACTUAL
HOUSING FOR PEOPLE LIVE IT AND
THAT'S AND THAT'S WHAT I THINK
WE HAVE TO. ENSURE THAT WE DO.
OTHER THAN THAT I AGREE WITH
EVERYTHING YOU SAID THOSE WITH
THESE ARE JUST MY
RECOMMENDATIONS BECAUSE. YOU
KNOW I WAS INVOLVED IN
INTRODUCING A YOU KNOW
THOUSANDS OF UNITS INTO SAN
DIEGO WE TO A COMBINATION OF
CONDO CONVERSIONS WE DID. NEW
HOUSE IN WE DID MARKET RATE I
THINK THROUGH THIS PROCESS.
WE'VE WE'VE GOT OF. THERE'S
GOTTA THERE'S GOT TO BE SOME
DISCRETION GIVEN TO YOU TO
ALLOW TO WORK WITH THE
DEVELOPMENT SEEMS TO COME UP
WITH A MIX. A HEALTHY MIX OF
HOUSING AGAIN. IF YOU CREATE
SUPPLY I WILL CRITICIZE BUT IF
THERE'S SOME WAY TO. GUIDE THIS
PROCESS TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE
CREATING AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
THERE REALLY ARE WITH THAT WE
ARE CREATING A COMBINATION OF
MAYBE. APARTMENTS WITH MAYBE
SOME FOR OWNERSHIP. AND BRING
IN MORE OWNERSHIP IN THE
COMMUNITY IF THERE'S A WAY TO
DO THAT I THINK THAT WOULD BE
IDEAL AND I THINK WITH THAT
WOULD. CREATE MORE BY AN- FROM
FROM THE PEOPLE OF OUR
COMMUNITY AND. THE LAST THING I
WANT TO SAY IS SAN DIEGO WE'RE
TRYING TO REBUILD OUR OUR CITY
HALLAND IN SOME CASES THERE'S
NO LAND IN SOME CASES VERY.
EXPENSIVE. AND IF THERE'S WAYS
TO PARTNER WITH LOCAL SINCE
SOME OF THESE PROJECTS IN IN
AREAS WHERE WE HAVE A STATE
BUILDING THAT IS UNDER UTILIZED.
HAVE WE LOOKED AT EXISTING
FACILITIES ARE UNDER UTILIZED
FOR MAYBE A POTENTIAL REDUCE
MAYBE THAT IS THE SECOND PHASE.
GOING INTO NEXT YEAR AS YOU GO
THROUGH THIS PROCESS BUT
THERE'S VALUE IN THAT BECAUSE.
IN MY COMMUNITY THERE ARE SOME
STATE BUILDINGS ARE BEING
UTILIZED THEY DO HAVE STAFF TO
DO PER THEY ARE PROVIDING. A
BENEFIT TO THE COMMUNITY BUT
THEY'RE UNDER UTILIZED AND THEY
COULD BE ADDED TO AND THEY
COULD BE COMBINED WITH OTHER
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND OTHER
INITIATIVES SO. IT AS THAT
ARISES I HOPE YOU YOU'RE YOU'RE
OPEN TO THAT AND I HOPE YOU.
LOOK AT THE VARIOUS
POSSIBILITIES THAT CAN BE
EMPLOYED. COMPLETELY OUT SO YOU
HAVE OF ME JUST TO TWO QUICK
POINTS I CAN ONE WE WERE
DELIBERATELY LIBERAL AS I SAID
EARLIER IN TERMS OF TRYING TO.
PULLING HIS MANY PROPERTY AND
SO THAT WE COULD BE TOLD NO AS
OPPOSED TO SELL SCREEN THINGS
OUT WE'VE ALSO PRETTY
TRANSPARENT WITH ANYONE WHO'S
ASKED WE ARE HAPPY TO BE SECOND
GUESSED IF WE LIMIT SOMETHING
UNDULY. I'D RATHER YOU KNOW
HAVE SOMEONE TO TAKE THEIR
FINGER IN TAKING A BRING THAT
BACK IN A LITTLE BIT WITH AN
APARTMENT AND X. HAVE SOMETHING
EXCLUDED SO THAT'S WHY WERE
WERE YOU KNOW BACK CAUTIOUSLY
LOOKING FORWARD TO THE VOLUME.
OF RESPONSES WERE GONNA GET
ONCE THE MAP IS OUT BECAUSE I
THINK THAT'LL HELP YOU KNOW
KEEP US ACCOUNTABLE IN TERMS OF
PROPERTIES THAT YOU KNOW MAYBE
SHOULD HAVE BEEN A LIST THAT
WEREN'T HOPEFULLY THERE'S VERY
VERY FEW OF THOSE BUT WE WANT
TO SORT OF THAT SECOND CHECK.
AND YOU KNOW THINGS LIKE YOU
KNOW THERE'S A STATE OFFICE
BUILDING IN SAN DIEGO THAT WE
CONTROL THAT YOU KNOW IT'S IT
HAS BEEN DECLARED ACCESS.
ALREADY AT THIS POINT IN THE
LAST YEAR. THE PAR SPRINT ON
BUYING BUT EXECUTIVE ORDERS I
THINK. YEAH WE ARE WE ARE
LOOKING AT THINGS PRETTY
BROADLY AND HOPEFULLY EVERYBODY
WILL BE PLEASANTLY SURPRISED AT
WHAT'S AS WHAT'S ON THE LIST.
AND IS THIS BEING THIS IS
PROCESS BEING ADVERTISED
THROUGH YOUR WEB PAGE IS THERE
A DITCH A DESCRIPTION OF THE
PROCESS THE FOLLOWING AND- A
WHAT POINT YOU REACH MILESTONES
AND YEAH THERE'S A FIGHT BIDS
UNDIGESTED WEBSITE UNDER MY
DIVISION THERE IS AN EXECUTIVE
ORDER PAGE IT OUTLINES BECAUSE
THE WORK WE'VE DONE WHAT THAT
MEANS WHAT THE NEXT STEPS ARE.
THAT'S WHERE THE HEATING APPLE
TO GET POSTED SO IT'LL BE SORT
OF THE CENTRAL HUB FOR
COMMUNICATIONS FOR THE EFFORT.
OKAY THANK YOU CENTER THERE IS
A. OUT OF THAT OKAY PAGE RIGHT
HERE IN YOUR IN YOUR- FOLDER AS
WELL CENTER BRADFORD. THANK YOU
I JUST WANT TO FALL BACK UP ON
THE HOMELESS ISSUE AND MOST
HOUSING THAT CENTERED AROUND
HOMELESS IS TEMPORARY. AND SO
WHAT PERCENTAGE OF THIS HOUSING
THAT IS TARGETED FOR
HOMELESSNESS WILL BE PERMANENT
HOUSING BECAUSE THE GOVERNOR
SENT A LETTER GOVERNOR BROWN
SIMILAR TO THE SENATE. STATING
PROPERTIES THAT WERE NEVER
MEANT TO BE PLACES FOR PEOPLE
TO LIVE CAN ONLY BE USED AS
TEMPORARY HOUSING IS THAT THE
FORMER YOU GUYS ARE STILL IT
HEARING TO. WE'RE NOT
APPROACHING THIS FROM A
TEMPORARY HOUSING WE'RE LOOKING
AT PERMANENT HOUSING
OPPORTUNITIES AND RENTAL
HOUSING BEING THE MAIN DRIVER
OF WHAT WE'RE EXAMINING RIGHT
NOW OF PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING FITS WITHIN ADVANCE.
AND SO WE HAVE PROGRAMS THAT
EACH CD THAT SERVICE THAT
THERE'S A FUNDING RIGHT NOW
AVAILABLE FOR PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
AND TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AS
WELL TO SUPPORT THAT SO EVEN ON
THOSE SITES THAT WERE DEEMED
NOT IDEAL. FOR HOUSING YOU WILL
BE PLACING IF YOU'VE FIND A
PARCEL AND YOU WOULD FOR. SORRY
I MISSPOKE NO FOR THINGS THAT
ARE DETERMINED NOT TO BE
FEASIBLE FOR HOUSING WE'RE NOT
LOOKING TO DEVELOP THEIR AS
PART OF THIS SO THAT COULD BE.
ADJACENT SEES IT COULD BE SITE
CONTAMINATION COULD BE THINGS
THAT WE JUST CAN'T THE ABSENT
OUT BUT I MEAN BUT SOME THINGS
MIGHT JUST BE YOUR CLOSE
PROXIMITY TO A FREEWAY OR
SOMETHING AND HE SAID. I MIGHT
NOT DEVELOP BUT IT IT'S
AVAILABLE LAND OWNED BY THE
STATE OR THE COUNTY YEAH I
THINK THIS IS WHERE WE'RE GOING
TO BE EXPLORING YOU KNOW AND SO
IN THE WORLD OF HOW WE'VE BEEN
PRIORITIZING WE'RE LOOKING FOR
SOME OF THE SPECIFIC FACTORS
THAT WE OUTLINED TO SEE WHERE
THERE'S- NATURALLY GOOD FITS.
I'M BY YES THERE ARE CERTAINLY
PROPERTIES WITHIN THE INVENTORY
THAT OUR HIGHWAY ADJACENT OR
MAYBE A LITTLE BIT MORE REMOTE
WILL CONTINUE TO EXPLORE THOSE
NOT SAYING THAT IT'S A NO
NEVER. I AM BUT JUST THE
QUESTION OF WHEN WILL CERTAINLY
COME UP. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU. YOU BEING HERE THIS
MORNING THANK YOU. HE OUR NEXT
PANEL. TITLED THE ROLE OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AFFORDABLE HOUSING
ORGANIZATIONS WILL HAVE JOHN
DUNBAR MAYOR TOWN OF YACHT BILL.
AND IT SAYS SECOND VICE
PRESIDENT LEE OF CALIFORNIA
CITIES I JUST WANT TO MAKE IT
KNOWN HE IS GOING TO BE OR IS
THE FIRST VICE PRESIDENT. SO
THAT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE DAVID
SISTER ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR OF
HOUSING CALIFORNIA. YOU HEAR.
IN PEDRO GO GOV A SENIOR POLICY
MANAGER WITH THE NONPROFIT
HOUSING ASSOCIATION OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WELCOME ALL OF YOU
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE AND
MISTER DUNBAR MAYOR DUNBAR WILL
START WITH YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. GOOD MORNING TERRY DODD
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
AS THE CHURCH'S STATED I'M JOHN
DUNBAR MAYOR OF THE TOWN OF YON
PHIL AND THE CURRENT.
TRANSITIONING SECOND VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES IN BOTH MY
CAPACITIES I WANT TO EXPRESS.
MY AND OUR SUPPORT OF GOVERNOR
NEWSOME'S EXECUTIVE ORDER I
COMMEND THE GOVERNOR'S
LEADERSHIP TO INSPIRE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT IS ALL INCOME
LEVELS. I APPLAUD HIS
COMMITMENT TO SUPPORT LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WAS SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENT IN THE BUDGET. AS
WELL AS OTHER TOOLS THAT CAN
PROVIDE SOLUTIONS FOR
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS WHO
STRUGGLE TO BUY OR RENT HOUSING.
I TESTIFIED BEFORE THE ASSEMBLY
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE LAST
MONTH IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE IS
ONE OF THOSE TOOLS. THAT WOULD
CREATE AN ONGOING FUNDING
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN THE STATE I
CALIFORNIA CITIES IT WOULD JUMP
START THE PRODUCTION OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS. SB
FIVE WOULD PROVIDE CITIES AND
COUNTIES THE RESOURCES TO
SUBSIDIZE AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
INVEST IN RELATED
INFRASTRUCTURE AND ADDRESS
OTHER CRITICAL STATE PRIORITIES
LIKE CLIMATE CHANGE AND FIRE
WISE BUILDING. LOCAL GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS ARE PREPARED TO USE
THESE TOOLS TO SUPPORT THE
CONSTRUCTION OF BELOW MARKET
RATE UNITS. FOR FAMILIES
STRUGGLING TO AFFORD HOUSING
NEAR THEIR JOBS DEVELOP TRANSIT
ORIENTED HOUSING THAT WILL
REDUCE TRAFFIC CONGESTION
ENCOURAGE URBAN INFILL
DEVELOPMENT BY REHABILITATING
AND IMPROVING INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND PROTECT COMMUNITIES
ADVERSELY AFFECTED BY SEA LEVEL
RISE GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
AND OTHER SIGNIFICANT IMPACTS
OF CLIMATE CHANGE. QUICKEN SURE
SCENARIO WHERE THIS EFFORT IS
UNDER WAY AND MY COMMUNITY. THE
BILL IS A SMALL TOWN OF FEWER
THAN THREE THOUSAND RESIDENTS
IN THE HEART OF THE NAPA VALLEY.
IN NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT NAPA
COUNTY ADOPTED THE NATION'S
FIRST AGRICULTURAL PRESERVE. IN
ORDER TO ORDER TO PROTECT
AGRICULTURAL LAND AND OUR
REGIONAL ECONOMY. DESPITE LOCAL
EFFORTS INCLUDING THE PASSAGE
LAST YEAR OF A COUNTY WIDE 1%
INCREASE IN THE HOTEL TAX THAT
IS DEDICATED TO WORKFORCE
HOUSING PROJECTS. WE ARE FACED
WITH HIGH HOME PRICES AND LOW
INVENTORY THAT KEEP HOUSING OUT
OF REACH FOR MANY OF OUR
WORKING FAMILIES. THE LARGEST
EMPLOYER IN OUR COMMUNITIES THE
CALIFORNIA VETERANS HOME. WITH
CLOSE TO ONE THOUSAND MILITARY
VETERAN RESIDENTS AND NEARLY
NINE HUNDRED EMPLOYEES. UP TO
ONE HUNDRED CARE GIVER JOBS
REMAIN UNFILLED AT THE VETERANS
HOME MAINLY BECAUSE THE COST OF
LIVING DOES NOT ALIGN WITH
HOUSEHOLD INCOMES. OUR NAPA
VALLEY UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
CONTINUES TO EXPERIENCE
DECLINING ENROLLMENT IN LARGE
PART ALSO BECAUSE FAMILIES
CANNOT AFFORD TO LIVE IN THE
AREA. THE RELATED DROP IN STATE
FUNDING HAS RESULTED IN
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN BUDGET
CUTS AND IMMINENT CLOSURE OF
SEVERAL HIGH PERFORMING BUT
SMALL PUBLIC SCHOOLS INCLUDING
YOUR AWFUL ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
WHICH DATES BACK TO THE
EIGHTEEN EIGHTIES. FOR MORE
THAN THREE YEARS I'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH LEADERSHIP IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF VETERANS AFFAIRS
GENERAL SERVICES HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT AND THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE TO BRING
HOUSING TO PONDER UTILIZE
SECTIONS. OF THE SIX HUNDRED
PLUS ACRE VETERANS ON CAMPUS.
WE HAVE IDENTIFIED LOCATIONS ON
THE PROPERTY SUITABLE FOR
HOUSING AND THE TOWN OF YALTA
HAS COMMITTED ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR A
FEASIBILITY STUDY TO CREATE
HOUSING THAT COULD SERVE
EMPLOYEES. ALMOST VETERANS
AMONG OTHERS. GOVERNOR
NEWSOME'S EXECUTIVE ORDER HAS
GENERATED SIGNIFICANT MOMENTUM
AT ALL LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT TO
SUPPORT OUR EFFORTS AND YOU
DON'T FEEL AS WELL AS WITH
OTHER HOUSING PROJECTS IN
CITIES THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
WE AWAIT THE RELEASE OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
LIST AS DISCUSSED EARLIER.
IDENTIFYING PROPERTY SUITABLE
FOR HOUSING CITIES ARE PREPARED
RIGHT NOW TO PARTNER WITH THE
STATE AND THE DEVELOPMENT
INDUSTRY TO MOVE THE NEEDLE ON
HOUSING AFFORDABILITY AND
AVAILABILITY. AS PART OF THE
PARTNERSHIPS I REFERENCED A
MOMENT AGO WITH KEY STATE
AGENCIES THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES HAS OFFERED
TO HELP IDENTIFY MEMBERS CITIES.
JUST UNDER FOUR HUNDRED EIGHTY
MEMBERS. READY TO INCORPORATE
AVAILABLE ACCESS STATE PROPERTY
INTO THEIR HOUSING PLANS TO
HELP SPUR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT. THIS EXECUTIVE
ORDER PRESENTS AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO WORK IN COLLABORATION TO
HELP DETERMINE THE VIABILITY OF
BUILDING AFFORDABLE HOUSING
UNITS ON AXIS STATE PROPERTY.
IT WILL BE INTERESTING TO LEARN
MORE FROM THE G. S. AND H. E.
D. ON THE SET OF CRITERIA THEY
HAVE ESTABLISHED AND AGAIN
DISCUSSED EARLIER. AND HOW
WE'RE GOING TO PRINT PRIORITIZE.
SUITABLE SITES. WE ALL WE THE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES
ALSO HAVE OFFERED TO HOST A
WEBINAR TO EDUCATE OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COLLEAGUES ABOUT THE
EXECUTIVE ORDER AND THE
SUBSTANTIAL LEGISLATIVE DOLLARS
AVAILABLE TO PLAN DESIGN ENGAGE
THE DEVELOPMENT INDUSTRY TO
BUILD HOUSING. THE EXECUTIVE
ORDER STATES THAT QUOTE
FOSTERING HOUSING INNOVATION
WILL CATALYZE NEW CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRIES AND SPUR JOB GROWTH
IN THE STATE A QUOTE. AND
CITIES WELCOME THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PARTNER. THE ORDER ALSO
IDENTIFIES THE FINANCIAL
INCENTIVE THAT WILL RESULT FROM
PRIORITIZING ACCESS STATE OWNED
PROPERTIES FOR HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT. BY REMOVING WHAT
IS TYPICALLY THE MOST EXPENSIVE
ELEMENT OF HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
LAND COST THE STATE
ACKNOWLEDGES IT CAN FACILITATE
IMMEDIATE AND SUBSTANTIAL
PROGRESS THAT WILL RESORT THE
RESORT AND MORE HOUSING UNITS
ACTUALLY BEING BUILT. I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT MY STORY AND THE LEAGUE
SUPPORT OF THIS EFFORT. THANK
YOU AND I WELCOME ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU MAYOR MISTER SISTER.
AND WHAT WILL ENTER HAVE
QUESTIONS AFTER BUT THE OLD
BATTLES DONE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU DOCTOR DIED IN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE GOOD MORNING AND
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME I'M
DAVE IS A CERTAIN AND THE
ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR OF HOUSING-CALIFORNIA. HELLO HOUSING
CALIFORNIA IS THE VOICE IN THE
STATE CAPITAL FOR CHILDREN
SENIORS FAMILIES PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS AND
EVERYONE WHO NEEDS A SAFE
HOME. OUR MEMBERS INCLUDE THE
MOST SOPHISTICATED NONPROFIT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
COMMUNITY IN THE NATION. AS
WELL AS LOCAL AND REGIONAL
ORGANIZATIONS IMPLEMENTING
CUTTING EDGE APPROACHES TO
ENDING HOMELESSNESS. AND
RESIDENTS OF NON PROFIT ON
AFFORDABLE HOUSING COMMUNITIES.
WE ENVISION A CALIFORNIA WHERE
NO ONE IS HOMELESS AND EVERYONE
CAN AFFORD A SAFE STABLE PLACE
TO CALL HOME IN A HEALTHY
VIBRANT AND PROSPEROUS
COMMUNITY. YET ACCORDING TO THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING PARTNERSHIP
AND I HAVE COPIES OF THE REPORT
IF YOU'D LIKE. CALIFORNIA HAS A
SHORTAGE OF ONE POINT FOUR
MILLION HOMES AVAILABLE AND
AFFORDABLE TO THE LOWEST INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS. STRUGGLING THE MOST.
MORE THAN THREE QUARTERS OF
HOUSEHOLDS AT THE LOWEST INCOME
ARE PAYING MORE THAN 50% OF
THEIR INCOME. TOWARDS RENT.
MAKING THEM SEVERELY RENDON
BURDENED AND FORCING MANY
FAMILIES TO CHOOSE BETWEEN
PAYING FOR HEALTH CARE
GROCERIES. AND OTHER
NECESSITIES AND LEAVING ON ONE
PAGE WAY CALLING ON
HOMELESSNESS. MORE THAN A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE EXPERIENCE HOMELESSNESS
ON ANY GIVEN NIGHT IN
CALIFORNIA AND THE NUMBERS
RIGHT IS RISING. THAT'S ENOUGH
TO FILL THE ENTIRE CITY OF
PASADENA FOR EXAMPLE.
SACRAMENTO WE HAVE THE THIRD
FASTEST RISING RENTS OUT OF THE
FIFTY LARGEST METRO AREAS IN
THE NATION. AND MORE THAN FIFTY
FIVE HUNDRED PEOPLE EXPERIENCE
HOMELESSNESS ON A GIVEN NIGHT
MARKING A 19% INCREASE COUNTY
WIDE. THE LACK OF HOMES
AFFORDABLE TO LOWER INCOME
CALIFORNIANS AFFECTS
CALIFORNIANS OF ALL STRIPES BUT
PEOPLE OF COLOR ARE IMPACTED
THE MOST. MAKING THIS AN
ECONOMIC AND RACIAL JUSTICE
ISSUE AS WELL. TO SOLVE
PROBLEMS OF THIS MAGNITUDE WE
NEED BIG BALD OUT OF THE BOX
SOLUTIONS TO GET AT THE HEART
OF THIS ISSUE. WE NEED TO
PEOPLE LIVING ON MODEST BUDGETS
AND FOR THOSE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. GOVERNOR
NEWSOME'S EXECUTIVE ORDER
MAKING ACCESS STATE OWNED
PROPERTY AVAILABLE FOR SUCH
DEVELOPMENT. IS AN EXAMPLE OF
AN OUT OF THE BOX APPROACH THAT
WE WILL NEED ESPECIALLY IF IT'S
FOCUSED ON AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING. FOR THOSE STRUGGLING
THE MOST. EXPERTS NOW THIS
APPROACH WORKS THIS APPROACH
WORKS IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
ENTERPRISE COMMUNITY PARTNERS
RELEASED A REPORT CALLED.
PUBLIC BENEFIT FROM PUBLICLY ON
PARCELS EFFECTIVE PRACTICES AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPMENT.
ACCORDING TO THAT REPORT QUOTE
USING PUBLICLY OWNED PARCELS
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING CAN
INCREASE LOW AND MIDDLE INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS ACCESS TO HIGH
OPPORTUNITY NEIGHBORHOODS WHERE
PROPERTY VALUES ZONING AND SIDE
OF L. AVAILABILITY CAN MAKE
HOUSING SERVING THESE
POPULATION SCARCE. IT CAN ALSO
INCREASE THOSE HOUSEHOLDS
ACCESS TO EMPLOYMENT TRANSIT
COMMUNITY CENTERS HEALTH CARE
SERVICES AND SCHOOLS AND QUOTE.
THIS POLICY PROVIDES SEVERAL
OPPORTUNITIES SIMULTANEOUSLY
ADVANCING BOTH LAND USE AND
FINANCE STRATEGIES FIRST IT
FACILITATES INCLUSION BY MAKING
LAND AVAILABLE IN PLACES THAT
MIGHT OTHERWISE EXCLUDE LOW
WAGE WORKERS OF COLOR. SECOND
IT REDUCES THE COST OF LAND
WHICH ACCOUNTS FOR AROUND 10%
BUT CAN ACCOUNT FOR AS MUCH AS
40% OF BUILDING COSTS. AND
THIRD IT MAKES MORE LAND
AVAILABLE FOR MULTI FAMILY
DEVELOPMENT WHICH IS CRITICAL
GIVEN THAT MORE THAN THREE
QUARTERS OF RESIDENTIAL LAND IN
CALIFORNIA IS ON FOR SINGLE
FAMILY HOMES. HOUSING
CALIFORNIA PLOTS GOVERNOR
NEWSOME'S INITIATIVE TO STATE
LAND TO FACILITATE THE
DEVELOPMENT OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FOR CAL FOR
CALIFORNIANS LEFT BEHIND IN THE
ECONOMY. IT ADDS A CRITICAL
TOOL TO THE TOOL BOX MOREOVER
THE STATE'S LEADERSHIP AND
PRIORITIZING PUBLIC LAND FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING SUCH A
STRONG EXAMPLE FOR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO FOLLOW. IT
HIGHLIGHTS THE NEED FOR STRONG
ENFORCEMENT OF LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS CURRENT
OBLIGATIONS UNDER THE SURPLUS
LAND ACT WHEN LOCAL AGENCIES
SELL OR LEASE THEIR LAND UNDER
THAT ACT THEY MUST FIRST MAKE
OUT THE LAND AVAILABLE TO
NONPROFIT AFFORDABLE OUSING
DEVELOPERS. AND IT DEMONSTRATES
THE IMPORTANCE OF PASSING
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TANGS AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SIX WHICH IS CO
AUTHORED BY SENATOR WINNER. AND
WOOD STRENGTHENING CLARIFY THE
SURPLUS LAND ACT. THIS
EXECUTIVE ORDER IS NOT A CURE
ALL WHEEL STEER STONE AND MUCH
MORE ON GOING STATE FUNDING TO
HELP HARD WORKING CALIFORNIANS.
AFFORD A DECENT PLACE TO LIVE
THROUGH CURRENCY CURRENT
LEGISLATION LIKE A. B. TOWN AND
SB FIVE AS MENTIONED. WILL NEED
MORE LAND USE CHANGES TO MAKE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
EASIER THROUGH BILLS LIKE AB
SEVENTEEN SIXTY THREE. AND WE
NEED MORE PROTECTION FOR
TENANTS AND MORE MEASURES TO
PREVENT PEOPLE FROM FALLING
INTO HOMELESSNESS IN THE FIRST
PLACE LIKE SB THREE TWENTY NINE
AND AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO. BUT
THIS ORDER MAKES A BIG
DIFFERENCE PRACTICALLY AND
FINANCIALLY. AND COMBINED WITH
THE INVESTMENTS IN THE BUDGET.
AS WLL AS BILLS CURRENTLY
MOVING THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE.
THIS ORDER SENDS A STRONG
MESSAGE THAT OUR GOVERNMENT IS
SERIOUS ABOUT SOLVING THE
HOUSING AFFORDABILITY CRISIS.
HOUSING CALIFORNIA AND OUR
MEMBERS LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION TO WORK
OUT THE DETAILS OF
IMPLEMENTATION. TO ENSURE THAT
THE GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER
IS AS EFFECTIVE AS POSSIBLE A
CRITIC MORE AFFORDABLE HOMES
AND PERMANENT SUPPORT OF HOMES
FOR CALIFORNIANS STRUGGLING THE
MOST. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MYSTERY
AVAIL. GOOD MORNING CHAIR DODD
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME MY NAME IS PEDRO GOLF ALL
AND I'M THE SENIOR POLICY
MANAGER WITH THE NONPROFIT
HOUSING ASSOCIATION NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA THOUGHT PROFIT
HOUSING ASSOCIATION OF THE
CALIFORNIA IS A LONG STANDING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION CELEBRATING OUR
FORTIETH ANNIVERSARY THIS YEAR
WE REPRESENT THOSE WHO BUILD
AND PRESERVE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND OUR MISSION IS TO SEE A BAY
AREA WHERE EVERYONE HAS AN
AFFORDABLE PLACE TO CALL. HOME
AND SO WE ARE HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
EXECUTIVE ORDER ON SURPLUS
LAND. BECAUSE PRIORITIZING
SURPLUS LAND FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IS A CRITICAL PART OF
THE SOLUTION TOWARDS BUILDING A
FUTURE WHERE EVERYONE IN
CALIFORNIA CAN HAVE AN
AFFORDABLE PLACE TO CALL HOME.
AS MY COLLEAGUE DAVID MENTIONED
CALIFORNIA IS EXPERIENCING A
HISTORICAL AFFORDABLE HOUSING
WELL HISTORICAL HOUSING CRISIS.
AND WITH SIX OF THE NATION'S
TEN MOST EXPENSIVE. AND SO WHEN
WE LOOK AT SOLUTIONS THAT CAN
TURN UNUSED AND UNDER UTILIZED
PUBLIC LANDS INTO PUBLIC CARD
MY PRIORITIZING THAT PLANNED
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING WE TEND
TO BE VERY SUPPORTIVE.
GENERALLY THE PROBLEM IS THAT
WE DON'T KNOW AND UP UNTIL THE
SIX SECOND OF ORDER WE DIDN'T
KNOW WHERE THAT LAND WISE. AND
EVEN IF THE SITES WERE KNOWN IT
WAS DIFFICULT AND IT IS
DIFFICULT AND GENERAL TO
DETERMINE WHETHER THOSE SITES
ARE VIABLE FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT. AND
WITHOUT CLEAR PRIORITY FROM THE
STATE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPERS ARE TYPICALLY NOT
COMPETITIVE FOR ACQUIRING THOSE
SITES AND DEVELOPING THEM TO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. IN THE BAY
AREA A STUDY CONDUCTED BY THE
METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION IDENTIFIED OVER
SEVEN HUNDRED ACRES OF PUBLICLY
OWNED LAND WITHIN HALF A MILE
OF HIGH QUALITY TRANSIT. THAT
OUR CUP ALSO COMPETITIVE FOR
STATE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
FUNDING. JUSTICE CREAM OF THE
CROP SITES CAN ACCOMMODATE
BETWEEN TWENTY ONE THOUSAND TO
THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND NEW
AFFORDABLE HOMES AND PRIME
LOCATIONS THROUGHOUT THE
REGION. IF YOU WERE TO EXPAND
THIS UNIVERSE OF PUBLICLY OWNED
PARCELS PARCELS BEYOND JUST
THOSE THAT ARE WALKABLE. IN
PRIME TRANSIT ORIENTED
LOCATIONS THAT NUMBER WILL
LIKELY EXPAND TO A FEW THOUSAND
ACRES IN THE BAY AREA ALONE.
AND IT DOESN'T TAKE MUCH
IMAGINATION TO EXTRAPOLATE THAT
IF YOU'RE LOOKING AT THE ISSUE
STATE WIDE. THIS WOULD
CORRESPOND TO LIKELY TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF ACRES AVAILABLE
THAT COULD BE MADE AVAILABLE
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING TO HOUSE
ALL CALIFORNIANS. THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING PARTNERSHIP
CORP A CORPORATION ESTIMATES
THAT THE STATE TO A SHORT ONE
POINT FOUR MILLION AFFORDABLE
HOMES. TO FULLY HOUSE
CALIFORNIANS OF ALL INCOME
LEVELS. WE ALREADY HAVE THE
LAND NOW THAT COULD BE USED TO
HOUSE THESE CALIFORNIANS. AND
SO. WHAT MAKES IS REALLY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE GOVERNOR'S
EXECUTIVE ORDER IS THAT IT
HELPS ADDRESS EACH OF THE
ISSUES THAT IDENTIFIED EARLIER
FIRST THE EXECUTIVE ORDER
CREATES A STATEWIDE DATABASE OF
SURPLUS SURPLUS STATE OWNED
LAND THAT COULD BE USED FOR
DOUBLE HOUSING. PROVIDING THE
TOOLS TOWARD DEVELOPERS TO
QUICKLY IDENTIFY OPPORTUNITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THAT COULD
BE USED TO BUILD MORE
AFFORDABLE HOMES SECOND THE
EXECUTIVE ORDER WINDOWS DOWN
THE TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
SURPLUS STATE SITES TO JUST
THOSE THAT COULD BE MADE MOST
QUICKLY AVAILABLE TO
ACCOMMODATE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
EXPEDITING THE PROCESS THAT THE
BALLOT BRISCOE THROUGH. AND
THIRTY EXECUTIVE ORDER PROVIDES
CLEAR DIRECTION TO ISSUE A
REQUEST FOR PROPOSALS FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
ON THOSE SITES BECAUSE WITHOUT
CLEAR DIRECTION FROM THE STATE
pEVEN IF THE SITES ARE BOTH
KNOWN AND VIABLE FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT THEY CAN
SIT VACANT FOR A LONG TIME OR
THEY CAN BE USED FOR OTHER
PRIORITIES BECAUSE THERE'S
ALWAYS OTHER PRIORITIES EVEN
WITH AN AFFORDABLE HOUSING
CRISIS. AND SO NPH SO
SUPPORTIVE OF THE CHANGES THAT
WE ARE CO SPONSORING
LEGISLATION THAT WILL DO MUCH
OF THE SAME AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
WHICH IS AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY SIX
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHANGE. WHAT
THAT BILL WILL DO IS IT WILL.
ALSO HELP IDENTIFY SITES THAT
ARE OWNED BY LOCAL AGENCIES
CLARIFY THE PROCESS THAT LOCAL
AGENCIES CAN TAKE TO PRIORITIZE
STILL SITES FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. AND CREATES MUCH
NEEDED ENFORCEMENT MECHANISMS.
AND SO WHILE PUBLIC LAND IS NOT
THE COMPLETE SOLUTION TO OUR
STATE'S HOUSING CRISIS WHEN
COUPLED OF OTHER CHANGES THAT
WE HAVE SEEN IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. HE CAN HAVE A
TREMENDOUS IMPACT TO MAKE A
SIGNIFICANT DENT IN OUR FOR
DOUBLE HOUSING NEED. AND SO
ENCLOSING MY TESTIMONY I WOULD
LIKE TO LEAVE YOU WITH AN
EXAMPLE OF EXACTLY HOW A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT HAS PARTNERED WITH
AN AFFORDABLE DEVELOPER. TO
MAKES STATE SURPLUS LAND
AVAILABLE FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING SO EVEN HOUSING LOCATED
IN HAYWARD CALIFORNIA. WORKED
WITH OF THE CITIES OF HAYWARD
AND CASTRO VALLEY TO ACQUIRE A
PARCEL THAT WAS PREVIOUSLY
OWNED BY CALTRANS ALONG HIGHWAY
TWO THIRTY STATE HIGHWAY TWO
THIRTY FOUR. AND IS NOW IN THE
PROCESS OF DEVELOPING THAT SITE
TWO SEVENTY TWO NEW OF INTER
SEVENTY TWO NEW FFORDABLE
HOMES THAT WILL BE AFFORDABLE
TO FAMILIES MAKING BETWEEN
2260% OF THE AREA MEDIAN INCOME
WHICH TRANSLATES TO. ROUGHLY
BETWEEN TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR TWO SEVENTY FOUR
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR FOR A
FAMILY OF FOUR. THAT IS SO
DESPERATELY NEEDED IN ALAMEDA
COUNTY AND WE EXPECT THAT TO BE
COMING OUT SHORTLY. AND SO WE
THINK AND ASSERT THAT A FOR
THAT SIR SLAM'S HAS A
TREMENDOUS POTENTIAL TO ADDRESS
OUR STATE TO FOR A HOUSING
CRISIS. AND WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR
THIS EXECUTIVE ORDER SO THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK ON THIS MATTER. AND
WE'RE HAPPY THE NONPROFIT
HOUSING ASSOCIATION NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA IS HAPPY TO BE A
RESOURCE TO YOU AND THE
ADMINISTRATION AS YOU CONTINUE
TO BOTH IMPLEMENT THIS ORDER
AND ON MATTERS PERTAINING TO
THE USE OF SURPLUS LAND FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK YOU ALL VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR A. CUSTOMER TODAY
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS FROM.
SEC MEMBERS THE SENATE
COMMITTEE. SEE THE SCENE CENTER
NIELSEN PLEASE. BUT I ASK ANY
OF YOU JUST TO MAKE AN
OBSERVATION IF YOU WOULD AS YOU
ARE. ARE LOOKING FROM YOUR OWN
PERSPECTIVES ABOUT THE
PRESERVATION OF AGRICULTURAL
LANDS. IS THAT A CONCERN. OR DO
YOU. LOOK AT THAT AS
OPPORTUNITY FOR SUCH HOUSING.
CORD IF I MAY. YES IT'S A
CONCERN I AS I REFERENCED IN MY
STATEMENT WE HAVE AN
AGRICULTURAL PRESERVE IN NAPA
COUNTY HI WHICH IS A CRITICAL
COMPONENT OF OUR ENTIRE REGION.
ONE OF THE REASONS THAT I HAVE
WORKED SO DILIGENTLY WITH THE
STATE AGENCIES RELATED TO THE
VETERANS HOME IT IS LITERALLY
THE ONLY LARGE PARCEL THAT IS
VIABLE. IT DOES NOT. NEGATIVELY
IMPACT OUR AGRICULTURAL LANDS
SO WE HAVE A VERY UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITY AND NAPA COUNTY I'M
SURE THERE ARE OTHER CITIES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA THAT HAVE
SIMILAR SETS OF CIRCUMSTANCES
THAT. THEY DON'T WANT TO SEE
VIABLE AG LAND CONVERTED TO
HOUSING IF IT IS AFFORDABLE SO
WE ARE TRYING TO FIND ALL THE
OPPORTUNITIES ARE SHORT OF THAT
TO BRING THE HOUSING NEEDS TO
OUR OUR COUNTY. JUST AT THAT
TYPICALLY THOSE TYPES OF PLANTS
THEY DON'T EVEN MAKE IT ONTO
THE LIST BECAUSE FOR WHAT WE
WERE TALKING ABOUT AS FAR
SURPLUS PUBLIC LANDS IT NEEDS
TO BE IDENTIFIED AS SURPLUS NO
LONGER NEEDED FOR. WHATEVER USE
THAT WAS PURCHASED FOR
AGRICULTURAL LANDS TEND TO BE A
PROTECTED USE AND THAT'S NOT
SOMETHING DIED WE LOOK AT OUR
OUR DEVELOPERS ARE TYPICALLY
INTERESTED IN. AMIR DUNBAR I
FIRST OF ALL PER SHEET THE
LEAGUE AND YOUR PERSONAL A
SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
EXECUTIVE ORDER. BUT I DO I'D
LIKE YOU TO COMMENT WE HEARD
FROM MISTER KINNEY ABOUT THE
PROCESS AT THIS GOING TO HAPPEN
I ASK YOU TO. YOU KNOW IN
VISION AND GIVE ME YOUR THàNH
YEAH WHAT THE COMMUNITY YOUR
COMMUNITY AND OTHER COMMUNITIES
FOR EXAMPLE OF THIS PROCESS THE
HAPPENS BEYOND THE OROVILLE
AREA WITH REGARD TO THE- TO THE
VETERANS HOME AND- IN ADDING
THAT IS THAT GOING TO BE
SOMETHING THAT'S GOING TO BE.
THE DIFFICULT FOR THE COUNCIL
TO GRAPPLE WHETHER YOU'RE
PLANNING DEPARTMENT OR- AT THE
FIRST THE- YEAH THAT NIMBY
FACTOR. BEING PLAYED OUT. WELL
THERE'RE IS AS I MENTIONED FOR
AT LEAST THREE YEARS IF NOT
MORE I'VE BEEN WORKING ON
ELIMINATING ANY TYPE OF EITHER
HESITATION OR NEGATIVITY ABOUT
BRINGING HOUSING TO THE
VETERANS HOME ONE OF THE WAYS
THAT HAS BEEN SUCCESSFUL IS
PRIORITIZING THAT HOUSING FOR
LOWER INCOME LEVEL WORKFORCE
PRINCIPALLY THE CARE GIVERS AT
THE VETERANS HOME ITSELF
SECONDARILY I SEE IT IN THIS IS
MY VISION THEN REACH OUT TO
HOMELESS VETERANS PROVIDING
LONG TERM OR TRANSITIONAL
HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES. TO
CONTINUE THE MISSION. OF
SERVING VETERANS ON THAT
PARTICULAR PROPERTY BUT FROM
THE VERY GROUND LEVEL AND YOUNG
FILL ALL THE WAY UP TO YOUR
OFFICE IN OTHERS HERE IN
SACRAMENTO THERE'S UNIVERSAL
SUPPORT WE ALL RECOGNIZE. THE
NEED FOR MORE HOUSING
ESPECIALLY BELOW MARKET RATE WE
HAVE THE STATE SUPPORT THROUGH
TOOLS AS A REFERENCE I GUESS BE
FIVE AND OTHER SIGNIFICANT
RESOURCES THAT HAVE NOT BEEN
AVAILABLE TO US AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL BEFORE AND SO. EVERYONE
FROM LOCAL FOUNDATIONS THAT
HAVE BEEN OF FUNDING HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS TO NONPROFIT
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
ORGANIZATIONS ARE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS LAW ENFORCEMENT
PUBLIC EDUCATION ALL LEVELS
HAVE SHOWN SUPPORT AND INTEREST
AND THEY JUST CONTINUE TO ASK
ME WHY AREN'T WE ALREADY
DIGGING SHOVELS ON THE GROUND
AND I SAID WELL I'M- COMING TO
SACRAMENTO TO FIND OUT. YEAH
WHAT YOU SAID THERE ARE ALSO
GOT ME TO BE THINKING ABOUT YOU
KNOW WHAT I WAS COUNTY
SUPERVISOR WE HAD DIFFICULTY
DOING. A WORK FORCE HOUSING.
WHERE YOU TARGET. HOUSING
BECAUSE OF LAWS THAT DON'T
ALLOW YOU TO TARGET LIKE A
COMPANY THAT'S GONNA WANT TO DO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR EXAMPLE
COMPANY THAT'S COMING INTO THE
AREA IT'S A REQUIREMENT THAT
THEY SET ASIDE LAND AVAILABLE
FOR HOUSING TRYING TO BUILD
SOME HOUSING OR GET SOME OFF
SITE HOUSING. BUT IT'S VERY
VERY DIFFICULT TO BE ABLE TO
SAY. THIS HOUSE A IS FOR YELLED
DEPLOYS THIS COMPANY FIRST
BEFORE ANYBODY ELSE COULD BE
CONSIDERED MOREOVER I HEARD
MISTER SAKE AND MISTER KINNEY
TALK ABOUT YOU KNOW. JOB
CENTERS HAVING IT THESE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECTS
BEING CLOSE TO EDUCATION
CENTERS AND JOB CENTERS IT MAY
BE SOMETHING WORSE SOME POLICY
CHANGE HERE AT THE LEGISLATIVE
LEVEL TO ALLOW SOME OF THESE
PLACES TO BE ABLE TO DIRECT.
HOUSING TO CERTAIN GROUPS YEAH
MAYBE SOMETHING THAT WE MIGHT
WANT TO DO AND I'D LIKE TO GET
YOUR YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT ALL
OF YOU. YEAH I MEAN IT'S
SOMETHING. THAT WE'D BE
INTERESTED IN EXPLORING AND
CERTAINLY WOULDN'T WHEN WE
THINK ABOUT THE PARTICULAR
GROUPS THE NEED TO BE TARGETED
AND FOCUSED ON FOR FERTILIZING
AS I SAID IN MY REMARKS. WERE
THING ABOUT PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS AND FOLKS AT THE-
SORT OF THE BOTTOM OF THE
INCOME LEVEL PEOPLE EXT AT 50%
OF THE ARMENIAN MEDIAN INCOME
AND BELOW AND I JUST WANT TO
CLARIFY MANY MANY IF NOT NEARLY
ALL OF THOSE FOLKS ARE ALSO
PART OF THE WORK FORCE THEY MAY
BE WORKING MINIMUM WAGE JOBS.
MULTIPLE JOBS BUT THEY ARE
FOLKS. AND ARE ARE WORKING AND
CONTRIBUTE TO THE ECONOMY AND
ARE PROVIDING CRITICAL SERVICES
IN OUR COMMUNITIES. SO YOU KNOW
THAT THOSE ARE FOLKS WE WANT TO
CONTINUE TO TARGET WHILE ALSO
THINKING ABOUT SPECIFIC
POPULATIONS AND I'M NOT SURE
EXACTLY WHAT YOU HAVE IN MIND
BUDGET LET'S JUST TAKE FOR
EXAMPLE IN THE OUGHT FILL FOR
FROM YOU KNOW IF YOU THAT'S
THAT STATE WORKERS THAT ARE
WORKING THERE AND- VERY MUCH IN
NEED OF. AFFORDABLE HOUSING
THEY MEET ALL THE CRITERIA AND
THEN YOU HAVE SOMEBODY FROM
LIKE COUNTY FOR EXAMS. NO
OFFENSE TO ANYBODY FROM LIKE
COUNTY I'M JUST TALKING ABOUT
TRAFFIC. YOU KNOW GOING FROM
YOUR BILL ALL THE WAY THROUGH
THE NAPA VALLEY ALL THE WAY UP
DANGEROUS. YOU KNOW ROADS I
THINK LOOKING AT SOME OF THESE
THINGS IS. YOU KNOW IT IT I
THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO
SOLVE OTHER ISSUES LIKE WE HAVE
A TRAFFIC ISSUES IN THOSE TYPE
OF THINGS SO WE HAVE JOBS SHE
ADDS WE OUGHT TO BE LOOKING AT
THOSE TYPE OF PARAMETERS WERE
MORE PLANNING. AND REAL QUICK
AND BEFORE. REMARKS BUT WE
WOULD MEAN A HOUSING CALIFORNIA
CERTAINLY AGREES AND THERE WERE
THERE WERE COMMENTS ABOUT THIS
FROM H. CITY INTO GS AS WELL AS
FROM THE MAYOR. ABOUT THE AND.
AS WELL AS YOU CHAIR DOT ABOUT
THE IMPORTANCE OF PLACING.
APPROXIMATE TO TRANSIT WALKABLE
COMMUNITIES ALL OF THAT REDUCES
VMT IS REDUCES GHG EMISSIONS IN
FACT THERE WAS ANOTHER REPORT
DON ALSO BY THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING PARTNERSHIP ALONG WITH
TRANSFORM THAT SHOWED THAT WHEN
YOU PLACE. FOR MORE HOUSING
NEAR TRANSIT YOU GET THE BEST
BANG FOR YOUR BUCK IN TERMS OF
REDUCING GHG EMISSIONS AND
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED A
COMPARED TO WHEN YOU PLACE
HOUSING THAT SERVES HIGHER
INCOME POPULATION SO MERELY BY
PLACING. DEEPLY AFFORDABLE
HOUSING NEAR TRANSIT YOU ARE
GETTING THOSE ENVIRONMENTAL
OUTCOMES AS WELL. ENOUGH THANK
YOU YES SIR THE ONLY THING THAT
I WOULD ADD TO DAVID'S
EXCELLENT TESTIMONY IS THAT.
THE STATE ALREADY DOES
PRIORITIZE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
FOR CERTAIN CATEGORIES OF
PROFESSIONS SO FOR INSTANCE
BUILDING TEACHER HOUSING OR
FARM WORKER HOUSING YOU CAN
BUILD ON SCHOOL PROPERTY FOR
INSTANCE IF YOU HAVE A SCHOOL
DISTRICT YOU NEED TO EDUCATOR
YOU NEED TO HOUSE YOUR
EDUCATORS AND YOUR STAFF AND IF
THE SCHOOL DISTRICT USES TO DO
THAT. YOU CAN DO THE HOUSING
TARGETED TO THAT SEGMENT YOU
CAN ALSO TARGET VETERANS AND
YOU CAN ALSO TARGET FARMWORKERS
AND SO THERE IS PRECEDENT IN
STATE LAW THAT ALLOWS FOR THAT
TARGETING. BUT IT I GUESS MORE
BROADLY SPEAKING WE DO NEED ALL
OF THE ABOVE APPROACHES AND
ACTUALLY THE COUNTY OF NAPA HAS
AN EXCELLENT PROGRAM THE WORK
FORCE HOUSING PROXIMITY PROGRAM
THAT KEEPS DOWN PAYMENT
ASSISTANCE FOR PEOPLE WHO LIVE
WITHIN A CERTAIN RADIUS OF
THEIR JOBS AND WORK IN NAPA AND
NAPA COUNTY. AND SO AND SO WE
BELIEVE THAT WE NEED ALL OF
THAT. TO REALLY AND NAY ABLE
FOLKS TO LIVE CLOSE TO WHERE
THEY. THANK YOU AND I WOULD ADD
TO THAT AS WELL THAT. I THINK
WHAT'S HAPPENED IS WE'RE SEEING
THROUGHOUT THE STATUS THERE'S
BEEN. PAIN LEVEL THAT HAS
BECOME A CUTE SO THAT WE'RE
SEEING BUSINESSES CLOSE WE'RE
SEEING SCHOOLS CLOSE. WE'RE
WE'RE SEEING THE REAL IMPACTS
AND UNFORTUNATELY IT HAS TAKEN
SOME PERIOD OF TIME. BEFORE ALL
INDUSTRIES AND ALL LEVELS OF
GOVERNMENT THE DEVELOPMENT
COMMUNITY HAVE IDENTIFIED THIS
IS A CRITICAL PRIORITY. NOT
JUST A NAPA COUNTY BY USING MY
EXAMPLE I REACH OUT OF THE WORK
FORCE ALLIANCE OF THE NORTH BAY
TO BRING THE VOCATIONAL
COMPONENT TO THE HOUSING
PROJECTS NAPA VALLEY COLLEGE
BRINGING TE EDUCATIONAL PIECE
SO. THIS IS OF A MULTI LAYERED
SOLUTION THAT'S WHAT WE REALLY
NEED TO DO TO MAKE THE HOUSING
NOT ONLY EXIST BUT TO MAKE IT
EVEN MORE BENEFICIAL THROUGHOUT
THE COMMUNITY. OF HAVING THE
STATE'S PARTICIPATION IN
ALLOWING THE PRICING TO CALM
DOWN WHETHER IT'S THROUGH THE
ACCESS STATE PROPERTY CERTAINLY
THAT'S A CRITICAL PIECE BUT
ALSO OTHER. REVENUES THAT ARE
BEING MADE AVAILABLE THROUGH
LEGISLATION ARE GOING TO ALLOW
US TO HAVE. LOW INCOME VERY LOW
INCOME BELOW MARKET RATE WHICH
IS SO CRITICAL TO OUR WORK
FORCE TO GETTING YOUNG FAMILIES
TO BE ABLE TO EITHER RENT OR
OWN SO THEY CAN START BEING.
OWNERS OF HOUSING THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. THANKS TO ALL THREE
OF YOU FOR YOUR EXCELLENT
TESTIMONY APPRECIATED VERY MUCH
WE'RE GONNA GO TO PUBLIC
COMMENT AT THIS TIME IS THERE
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IT'S
HERE. THEY WOULD LIKE TO WEIGH
IN. PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME AND
WHERE YOU'RE FROM REPRESENT.
SIR CAN USE A MICROPHONE RIGHT
UP YOUR POLICE. YOU CAN USE
THAT ONE THAT'S FINE. HELLO
THANKS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY MY
NAME IS ROSS ROMERO I'M FROM
ORANGE COUNTY CALIFORNIA. I HAD
BEEN A REAL TO THEIR FOR TWENTY
FIVE YEARS. CRAXI WILL IN
ANAHEIM NORTH ORANGE COUNTY
AREA AND I'VE ALSO BEEN A
HOUSING ADVOCATE. CURRENTLY I
DO SO TO FACT SIT ON THE BOARD
OF A NONPROFIT HOUSING
CORPORATION IN SANTA ANA
CALIFORNIA CIVIC CENTER MARIO
HOUSING. ANYWAY. I JUST WANTED
TO SAY THERE WAS A MENTION HERE
OF THE WORD. CRISIS AND WE ARE
IN FACT IN A CRISIS IN ORANGE
COUNTY VOTE JUST TO GIVE A
LITTLE INSIGHT. AFFORDABLE IS
ANYTHING UNDER NINETY THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR. SO WE TALK
AFFORDABLE IN ORANGE COUNTY
WE'RE TALKING A FAMILY OF FOUR
THE MAKES LESS THAN NINETY
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR. AS WE
KNOW STATEWIDE RENTS HAVE BEEN
DRAMATICALLY INCREASED.
HOMEOWNERSHIP IS NEAR. VERY
DIFFICULT TO OBTAIN. AND I JUST
I'M NOT GONNA SAY MUCH MORE
THAN WHAT THEY SAID. BUT THERE
IS ONE ISSUE HERE YOU GUYS WITH
THE STATE NOW HAS THIS LAND.
THE GOVERNOR HAS DESIGNATED
THIS LAND ONE OF THE PROBLEM IS
LIKE AN ORANGE COUNTY. WE'RE
BUILT OUT. THERE IS NO MORE
LAND FIVE THERE THERE SINCE I
WAS NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE. I'VE
BEEN A REAL TO THEIR TWENTY
FIVE PLUS YEARS ANYTHING ANY
HOUSING THAT HAPPENS IN ORANGE
COUNTY. IS GONNA BE UP MORE
LAND. I THINK THE SAME HOLDS
TRUE YOU KNOW IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY EVEN MORE SO EVERYTHING
IS GOING UP THERE'S A MORE
LAND. SO WITH THIS INITIATIVE
YOU HAVE THE WHERE WITH ALL.
YOU KNOW TO PUT TO RENEW EASE
SOME OF THE PRESSURE DO WE ARE
SEEN IN THE URBAN AREAS AS WAS
MENTIONED BY THESE GENTLEMEN IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA. BUT AS WE
SEE VERY VERY MUCH SO ALSO IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND SO I
DON'T IT'S A GREAT INITIATIVE.
I JUST HOPE YOU SUPPORT IT AND
WE REALLY NEED TO FOCUS ON
HOUSING ON THE STATE BECAUSE
IT'S BECOMING UNOBTAINABLE TO
PEOPLE NOT ONLY IN THE
HOMEOWNERSHIP BUT IN THE RENTAL
OF PROPERTIES THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY VERY MUCH FOR BEING
HERE TODAY IN YOUR TESTIMONY
ANYBODY ELSE. WELL THAT
CONCLUDES THE HEARING TODAY I
WOULD REALLY LIKE TO THANK ALL
THE SPEAKERS I THINK WE GOT. A
LOT OF INFORMATION I'M REALLY
EXCITED ABOUT. THE DIRECTION
THAT THE APARTMENTS ARE ARE
TAKING ON THE GOVERNOR'S
EXECUTIVE ORDER. THEY'LL BE
MORE INFORMATION TO THE TO
FOLLOW BUT FOR NOW WILL
CONCLUDE THIS MEETING AND
THANKS FOR BEING HERE